[Musique]
tu as vu ce qui se passe là tout le
monde en parle au nom de quoi tu parles
tu rigoles ou quoi la radio ou à la télé
les journaux tout le monde a le truc
mais oui ce matin je suis allé au
pressing m'attends à tout moment pas à
l'autre c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu
trois camps en ligne l'aventuré en
parler aussi mieux si on parle lui aussi
fils en bas alors que tout le monde
chers amis chers ennemis bonsoir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en garde alors vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle
alors tout le monde en parle on parle
alors pour en parler avec nous ce soir
laurent ruquier bonsoir laurent
ressortir les formes inhabituelles
ça fait chier à gaillon bonsoir santé
stéphane bern
et mathilde seigner
alors les invités d'honneur en dernière
invitée d'honneur toujours en a toujours
en berne a demandé à ses fans pour la
bonne mais nés entre la fin ça commence
fort alors au sommaire ce soir ce soir
trois invités seront hyper mauvais
souvenirs il perdurer depuis la dernière
fois je sais vous poser des questions
quand il invitait cette règle 3 est
absolument trois invités y perdre yuv et
mathilde seigner jack lang et christine
deviers joncour
vous connaissez les consignes de neige
en cours celle qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle la [ __ ] de la république
voilà où la mata hari du périgord et la
[ __ ] de la république interviewé par
le gigolo de la monarchie je vais voir
c'est vouloir ensuite avec jack lang
nous parlons de ce qu'il fait rire et
des victimes du rire avec christine
deviers-joncour nous parlerons des
victimes du média avec en plus francis
lalanne et djamel bouras mais on
commence tout de suite par un tour de
table qu'est ce qui vous a fait rire
dernièrement laurent qu'est ce qui m'a
fait rire une bonne nouvelle dans la
semaine dont est un truc dont tout le
monde parle de faire une bonne nouvelle
c'est pas le fait qu'ils aient deux
front national ça pour moi c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on puisse dire aujourd'hui le
président du front national est un conte
hitlérien et maintenant celui des deux
qui s'enlisait me fait pas mal
qu'est ce qui vous a fait rêver
bâtie moi rien mais rien justement on
m'a demandé mais rien bayal mariage
évidemment monaco mais stéphane bern et
là il va en parler il va en parler mieux
que moi même si on dit que pour pouvoir
épouser cet allemand caroline de monaco
a dû épouser a dû demander
l'autorisation à jean pierre chevènement
penser que c'est vrai - berne absolument
pas ses joueurs en savoir un peu plus
sur sur ce sur ce mariage on n'a jamais
autant écrit sur quelque chose que
auquel personne n'a assisté quand même
c'est étonnant c'est marino il a fait
lui plus sa campagne ça fait cent ans 78
m
de fait sans eux deux ça fait ça le
drame c'est quand il y en aura 98 on se
demande laquelle il épousera qu'est ce
qui vous fait ben moi je suis un peu
embêté parce que je les aime bien mais
ce qui me font vraiment beaucoup et je
m'en lasse pas c'est quand même le psg
serait alors et j'ai alors enfouir je
suis me font rire et tout mais on leur a
jeté un sort
c'est pas possible le psg ils vont y a
un truc facile ça ils sont allés jouer
contre une équipe qui s'appelle de la
ville de thouars ils sont allés jouer at
war et alors miracle le psg je sais pas
si vous allez me croire dominer ils
menaient 2 0 s'est dit ça y est quoi
c'est la résurrection
vive le psg tout va mieux et maintenant
ils ont interrompu le match pour cause
de brouillard à la 67e minute avec des
mesures qui vont être prises contre le
psg par l'entraîneur déjà on va
supprimer les allocations familiales aux
parents des joueurs pensent que ça
[Applaudissements]
je reviens sur le mariage parce que je
suis au près des partenariats chez pas
mais est ce qu'elle est grosse ou pas
caroline parce qu'on dit qu'elle est
enceinte
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas j'étais
face ou le lien le genre alors j'ai payé
bon quelques rondeurs d'après les photos
oui alors il a fait l'amour avec bouvard
il restait alors si on en prend nos
archives une dernière fois qu'elle s'est
mariée c'était avec stefano casiraghi en
83 et bien l'enfant avait chez les
grimaldi
ils font que six mois de grossesse alors
la maison un privilège à mon avis non
classés des six mois de grossesse et je
pense que là ça va être pas mal à
regarder les photos du mariage je le
reconnais pas vincent lindon selmer dans
tout ça il est tombé 10 france assure t
il est un peu désespéré albert parce que
bon il se dit mais je vais tout seul
maintenant ça sony est lui dans une
station de sports d'hiver ont déclenché
la salle y va on va rester là dessus et
lui qu'il ait dit non plus qu'il ait dit
obama devrait quand même avoir des
précisions la liaison du prince albert
qu'il avait pendant les jeux olympiques
c'est fini ou pas ça me bobsleigh matile
vous êtes prête pour l'hyper view ouais
[Musique]
pensez à l'hyper view vous allez voir
première fois c'est un peu de terribles
comme salle hyper view mais gourmand on
s'y fait très bien donc après on a eu
dans cette émission adriana karembeu on
a eu laeticia casta avait d'abbas et
d'hyper v ous away et donc après c'est
tout noir mais tout s'apprend
donc après avoir eu la plus jolie fille
du monde on s'est dit qu'on allait
inviter la brèche énorme à la plume à la
plus drôle de la plus drôle mais non non
seulement vous êtes joliment plus en
plus gros à vous appeler mathilde cini
faut le dire aux gens parce que tout le
monde ne vous connais pas bien sûr
personne mais voilà donc vous êtes la
soeur d'emmanuelle seigner
ouais j'ai pu faire plus connu que vous
et surtout elle a épousé en inde
polanski à la croix de soeur emmanuelle
ouais et quand quand votre soeur s'est
pas commencer à vivre avec roman
polanski ça vous a inquiété ou non moi
ce qui leur est quand même drôle de
réputation en polanski quand est arrivée
en france à vous a pas inquiété d'une
inconduite ou pas du tout vous êtes la
petite fille de louis seigner ça je sais
pas si c'est à dire à grand-chose à
grand monde
enfin doyen de la comédie française
non mais c'est peut-être pas les jeunes
mais quand même oui ce que je voulais
c'est un peu je vous le dit jean louis
seigner évidemment mes vieux comme
rookie et moi je connais ma génération
j'ai invité dans un dîner envie de fait
semblant donc vous êtes né le 7 janvier
on dit ça ça intéresse absolument
personne je sais bien mais ça matin je
suis une île 6 7 janvier où les 7 à 10
mm c'est moins drôle alors c'est moi si
j'avais aujourd'hui un schéma de jeu 1-0
à chelsea comme c'est la règle en brique
et maman thierry pain et après on pour
la reine dans sa vie il s'est fait
monter les faits oui je pensais qu'ils
allaient sortir et on bourg la reine
on va voir s'ils jouent la semaine
prochaine en colère l'a vite moi donc à
partir de mercredi on vous voit dans
vénus beauté institut film de tonie
marshall avec nathalie baye bulle ogier
le bihan robert hossein claire nebout et
c'est un an vous jouez le rôle d'une
petite esthéticienne way s'inventa oui
c'est tout c'est tout un plein de femmes
dans un institut de beauté c'est très
bien moi j'ai très bien fait les progrès
canimarche ap
parce que j'avais vu que tinto avec
terrebonne d'un cône du talent elle a
fait des profits elle avait déjà fait un
très bon film avec audrey j'en sais rien
en face c'est un film qui est très très
aboutie les micheline presle donc filmé
ou serait elle qui est la maman de tenir
jeudi à emmanuelle riva elle pas dire
que des gens mais c'est un très beau
film très émouvant et qui regardera la
bande annonce à la fin on va vous voir
au mois de mars dans un film
comme rassurants l'a pas vue pour le
moment s'appelle belle-maman un film de
mazion c'est avec aguillon à william
avec catherine deneuve
c'est ce qu'a fait [ __ ] douce et salée
gabriel aghion c'est pour ce film que
vous avez perdu 8 kg ouais et dans le
film la vie dans l'au delà
en fait en fait vous explique l'hyper
view devinez combien d'erreurs se glisse
dans les questions de thierry ardisson
dit oui j'ai perdu on m'a demandé
oui on m'a dit enfin m'a dit c'est mon
contrat il faut faire du week end là
mais on arme et lui à l'avant le rôle
moi il faut que tu maigri un peu voilé
dans le tony marsh
justement c'est ce que je voulais
d'anthony marshall vous êtes bien jamais
également alors donc les débits qui nous
avaient perdu avant le 24 octobre après
le 24 octobre répondent à la déclaration
pourquoi l'eire 3 vous étiez en train de
les perdre au 24 octobre c'était quoi le
24 heures on va voir ce que c'était le
24 octobre magnéto
[Musique]
je sens bien que je t'aime j'ai un
problème c'est que je t'aime aussi c'est
mon nom est toujours les mêmes
c'est nous qui changeait le jour
du j'ai un problème
j'ai bien peur que je t'aime moi j'ai un
problème
j'en ai bien peur aussi en perdant
on y gagne
voilà donc ça c'était le 24 octobre
c'était chaud le show sylvie vartan a
été produit et réalisé par jérôme revon
avec stéphane gâteau et c'est là bas
voilà c'est là vous avez rencontré
laurent gerra ce je vais pas trop en
parler tout à l'heure parce que je
voulais qu'on vous voit ensemble et ça
s'est passé comment là vous êtes obligé
de me raconter je suis une curiosité
passionnée bien présentes que l'essai de
lyon laideur voilà c'est tournez manège
maintenant alors comment ça a été c'est
un coup de foudre f
ah ouais sur la chanson ouais pendant la
chanson de ouais ya des textes un peu
débile mais moi j'ai un problème je
crois bien que je t'aime et tout et
c'est vrai l'allégeance et on s'est
aimés sur cette chanson non mais c'est
vrai ça s'écoute foule et lé soir la
raison mais si c'est honnête c'est vrai
on s'est aimés sur cette chanson c'est
vous et vous inviter à dîner après en
sachet +6 il m'a invité mais on s'est
téléphoné et puis c'est généreux mais
après il m'a invité au monde à dîner
on a dîné vous a fait rire les a fait
rire bien sûr mais ça a marché parce que
j'aime j'ai vu des images interviews de
vous vous disiez moi si un jour je
rencontre un mec qui me fait marrer il
aura gagné donc c'est lui non mais senna
on n'a plus d'espoir non mais c'est tout
le reste un mois sont pas en voie
il fait rire évidemment mais c'est tout
c'est tout le reste c'est quoi tout le
rêve bas à l'intelligence tout ça sert à
quoi
non mais c'est pas quand vous êtes
plutôt atteignant 90 en revanche à des
âmes au dessus de 30 ans donc vous allez
vous changer
j'ai lu ça plus âgées aux issers qu'un
homme de mon âge qui à 31 ans je le
trouve vraiment là c'est pas possible
quoi on va voir on va voir encore un
petit bout de laurent gerra parce que
nous aussi voudrais je vous en prie 6
[Musique]
e
y en a marre d'entendre ces trois
couillons qui surgit
on nous bassine ce gros tas toute la
journée
esmeralda
beaumont
le
commence à nous gonfler avec leurs états
d'âme et le nom
sauter
ce
quasimodo n'a pas eu droit
se vider
gargouille ces trois crétins peuvent se
nomme
être sous le bras se fait pas
ce
[Musique]
oui il a réalisé il a réalisé un
véritable exploit parce que je pensais
bien regarder les images il ya catherine
trautmann qui rit ou et ça a payé assez
osé parce que comme c'est le succès oui
toujours les choses un peu mais vous
tirez sur les vaches sacrées pas sur les
ambulances ça que oui c'est toujours
plus risqué de d'attaqué quelque chose
qui est un succès et tout ça vous vous
étiez déjà très fan de johnny hallyday
dont qui vous a sûrement séduit en
imitant johnny hallyday 1
quand ils vous le fait que pour vous
avez bien mais quand vous êtes tous les
deux voulaient ben oui vous avez un nom
mais bien sûr quand même un truc que je
comprends pas chez vous c'est vous dit
quand je vois sardou je manque
m'évanouir
c'est physique ça m'inquiète et qui
s'avoue pas dans un journal je vais pas
inventer des trucs pareils
oui c'est fini maintenant c'était dur
pour ibiza
plus maintenant
mais j'aime beaucoup sardou camion
michel non mais c'est vrai alors ouais
c'est vrai j'ai toujours adoré non mais
non mais j'explique parce que quand on
quand on peut croire que c'est les gens
me disent oui m'enfin allez y les réacs
eu droit tu pas quoi moi je m'en fous
les artistes lors leur opinion et je
m'en contrefous je trouve que d'abord
ils n'ont pas affiché enfin on n'a pas à
savoir moi michel sardou quand il quand
il change il a une belle voix de johnny
me plaisait physiquement maintenant oui
la menace immédiate
vous avez une chose qui est très rare de
nos jours où tout le monde pense à peu
près la même chose nous dit penser la
même chose à une chose qui est très rare
c'est que vous dites peut-être parce que
vous n'êtes pas encore assez dans le
show biz ou peut-être parce que vous
êtes vraiment différente vous dites que
vous pensez si un peu quand vous par
exemple vous sortez un film se mêlent
vive la république et vous dit à ce
moment là que vous préférez chirac à jos
par eric rochant le réalisateur vous
insulte en vous disant m'enfin on dit
pas ça dans le show business tout le
monde est de gauche
dictée de gauche sinon tu réussiras
jamais et vous vous continuez à le dire
je ne suis pas hypocrite c'est bien ça
me fait que c'est rare ça
alors non mais moi j'ai moi je m'en
fiche un grand père il était gaulliste
on peut être bien être de droite ont
peut être bien de gauche veut dire ça
veut rien dire non je lis est rare on
sait les gens disent tous la même chose
par exemple quand vous dites que vous
aimez pas le rap que vous n'avez pas
détester ntm par exemple oui bah ça me
fait hôtesse de l'air non mais c'est
vrai nos thèmes vous dit tu les gagnes
du pognon ancrage sont sa société ça
vous énerve ça ntm jadoul ils me font
chier
ouais mais font chier il me forçait
parce qu'ils sont à la télé ils ont fumé
50p tard ils sont moches
ils sont sales et ils sont là vas-y
chanclu la société [ __ ] bave et ça ça
m'intéresse pas ce qu'ils font quand
même la société achète quand même c'est
leur dise quoi contrairement aux autres
agences fitch et social
alors est ce que en plus alors
maintenant vous vous êtes en train de
tourner un nouveau film avec cette année
c'est bien ah mais non mais attendez
non mais attendez moi je vais vous dire
un truc votre attachement à bien la
seconde l'attaché de presse va peut-être
vous engueuler
c'est sûr parce que j'en attendais mais
en tout cas s'occupe d'eux dit amer mais
les gens les gens qui regardent la télé
je peux vous dire que les gens qui
regardent la télé sont peu habitués à
autant de franchise et de ça c'est bien
parce que nous risquons n'est toutefois
qu'il faut bien dire que toutes les
conneries qu'on dit on en pense pas vous
êtes jalouses des stars du porno qui ont
des grosses bouche des gros seins et
faux pas du tout non pas du tout c'est
eux
je suis même je suis même fasciné qu'on
dépense autant d'argent et autant
d'énergie pour être encore plus moche et
aussi moche quoi
non mais la dcri
la descente j'ai surkiffé ravissante
comme d'ailleurs laetitia casta c'est
vachement bien ce qu elle a dit j'ai
entendu dans l'émission elle a dit non
moi je veux pas refaire parce que elle a
20 ans oui on verra dans 20 ans 15 à 20
ans il y avait à faire des trucs c'est
grand mais à 20 m2 elles le feront à 15
ans mais bien sûr nous on achète un
miroir qui va avec aussi ce qu'on va
faire sans qu'on est là dessus on va en
profiter pour regarder ça tombe bien
voyez la bande annonce donc de vénus
beauté institut et pièces avec notre
amie mathilde senard s'est lancé pour
asseoir une légère sensation de
picotement peut intervenir tube de colle
partout si la gêne persiste vous et
projets non je taille va d'ailleurs pas
de moi
et vous appliquer rapidement la crème
anti rougeurs sérénité en couche épaisse
savate et tout pâle c'est le fond de
teint tu parles tu es encore tombé sur
un as oui bon alors pourquoi cet
aquaplaning à base d'enzymes en décembre
janvier février
la peau bien entré dans l'hiver je suis
pâlichonnes et faut faire quelque chose
et cellules mortes se sont amassés comme
comme une fine moisissures sur la
surface de la peau us safa me donner la
peau de ses fesses pour le réparer le
visage comme un hymne au clean dernière
ils vont entretenir la poudre sa femme
le plus longtemps possible
vous faites les finitions n'en fait pas
la finition et les endroits spécialisés
on s'occupera de ce problème de beyrouth
alors maintenant tu la laisses
tranquille et curieusement morue tout
vécu bref le visage est asphyxié le
teint déprimé et la cliente se sent
vieillir
avec ce peeling on va des caps et voilà
je m'appelle antoine je suis amoureux
si je suis anti mais j'ai du travail bon
vous voyez ce type là bas mais les
minions la débauche yeux vous pouvez
voir ses yeux à cette distance jeu
presbytes
[Musique]
on va redonner à la peau un peu des
samoa
où
je vous ai dit la vérité on
moi
la ligue est-elle matin mais ça ne bouge
pas
au revoir madame beauté institut à
partir du 3 février dans toutes les
salles c'est un très bon film
alors merci beaucoup vous avez vu lee
perdu où l'aca a été lâchement à la sava
bon et jack lang me trouvais beau
bonsoir vous connaissez filmant patricia
gagnon laurent les pieds mathilde
seigner stéphane bern
[Musique]
alors en fait on vous a invité parce que
il fait beaucoup de questions de vous à
mon avis d'ici l'été
mais aussi pour un autre raison j'avais
absolument pour une autre raison c'est
que vous avez dit que laurent gerra
était rigolo et intelligent alors là où
l'amant comme vous avez la fiancée de
laurent gerra devant vous effectivement
vous êtes déjà vous êtes très copains
alors jack lang
vous avez une forme éblouissante ouais
c'est vrai il a dit ça vous avez une
forme une forme éblouissante on peut
dire votre âge non bah oui bien sûr
soixante ans par exemple parce que j'ai
refait pas tout à fait aujourd'hui suis
pas bon ménage
mais alors alors vous avez un secret
quand même c'est que vous dit on à
genoux pour embrasser bon mais pas on
n'a jamais fait vous avez un secret
c'est vous dit en fait noces porte comme
churchill sûr vous ne faites pas de
sport c'est de ce fait de votre forme je
me balade un peu quelques quelques
itinéraires à pied et un peu de ski de
temps à autre et voila voila mais vous
n'êtes pas ruiner la santé à faire là on
est à ses yeux la santé à faire du
jogging sûrement pas on en meurt bon
mais c'est bien parfois c'est un truc à
savoir alors vous êtes ministre de la
culture je le fus bas quand vous dites
que vous l'êtes pas personne ne vous
croira toute façon donc autant dire que
voulez vous d'autre
vous êtes président de la commission des
affaires étrangères
c'est pas c'est bien comme job c'est
passionnant j'aime les gêner relations
internationales voyage en tout cas ouais
peut alors ce que je suis très casanier
alors jaurès à paris beaucoup en avant
vers les lois mais à valéry giscard
d'estaing avant voulons lui et c'est une
autre stature ah bon lui il avait voyagé
déjà beaucoup pour les 9 à 10 ans
est ce que vous regrettez un peu votre
pré candidature de 95
c'est à dire on avance des histoires
anciennes oui ça fait quatre ans qu'on
soit au courant oui ça vous regrettez
pas de partie des choses qui vous
enrichissent il n'y a pas de regrets
mouais vous ne regrettez pas d'avoir des
jeux spa est un looser ça a dépassé ma
pensée et il a eu raison de me donner
tort très bien répondu alors vous êtes
maire de blois là je termine curriculum
vitae vous êtes maire de blois ce qui
vous a valu le surnom de langue de bois
mais j'espère que ce soir j'espère que
c'est pas de moi c'est toi et y redire
ce soir j'espère vous ne serez pas
langue de bois on vous accuse souvent de
courir après la modernité alors
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
le sentiment d'être un petit peu quand
même sur le plan de la modernité d'être
concurrencé quand même par cohn bendit
pour qu on n'est jamais assez nombreux
oui sauf que vous n'êtes pas des mêmes
partis aux deux parties nous important
dans la même famille d'accord est ce que
vous savez ce que ça veut dire courir
qu'europe1 pas spécialistes et des
réponses comme ça sans burqa ce que vous
lisez
non parce que j'ai vu que vous lisez les
inrockuptibles c'est ce que ça veut dire
quoi non du tout bon non c'est courir
c'est alors j'ai dit voyez maintenant
non mais c'est quoi je fais pas
attention ces huits hier non non non non
c'est en fait la tendre qua non la
théorie queer c'est de dire qu'il ya
plus seulement les hommes les femmes et
les homosexuels mais qu'en fait il ya
autant de chèques ski adam vie voilà
c'est fait beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
oui bien sûr et c est cela de répondre à
cette question vraiment en toute
franchise parmi tous les successeurs
vous avez eu à la culture
je vais les rappeler très vite il ya eu
jacques eu tout bon il ya eu philippe
françois léotard par françois léotard
avant il ya eu tout bon
il ya eu 12 blazy maintenant catherine
trautmann qui a été le meilleur à votre
avis il s'améliore au fur et à mesure
est-ce que vous allez être candidat du
ps aux européennes voilà une question
qui ne s'est pas posé à mon petit
cerveau encore vous c'est que ça l'a
décidé vous savez que la décision est la
décision va être prise le 10 février
vous le savez bien donc c'est dans
quinze jours laissez les socialistes
réfléchir oui ça leur prend du temps il
faut bien dire que j'ai soupesé partie
c'est vrai que j'ai ce pare-feu pas une
vie sinon pas de veut pas de vous non je
ne passais pas qu'il veut pas il a dit
que françois hollande était un bon
candidat
vous pensez que françois me sera un bon
candidat avec celle en candidat
meilleure femme de cumuler l'autre
partie du fromage y avoir de cumul c'est
ça le problème
donc vous savez pas franchement je ne
sais pas moi je trouve alors je peux me
permettre de vous dire ça vous feriez un
excellent quand je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas françois hollande
j'ose pas là dit serait un très bon
candidat c'est bien très bon gardien il
faut le choisir
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas victime
finalement d'une sorte de des mitterrand
10 à sion je sais pas je cherche à faire
oublier les les années mitterrand
mitterrand y est prévu à que vous seriez
pas au gouvernement il avait dit on va
abandonner superphénix bas mais jack
lang c'est vrai que vous avez pas renier
mitterrand est pourtant il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses qui sont sortis
depuis quelques années je vais pas vous
les listes et parce que tout le monde
les a en tête
bon vous malgré tout et c'est honorable
parce que veut dire vous êtes fidèles
malgré tout vous continuez à défendre la
mémoire du président mitterrand
plus que jamais et vous avez même créé à
blois un pont françois-mitterrand oui
bon est ce que finalement c'est passé à
votre problème est ce que est ce que
finalement pour épave
parce que des gens qui sont aujourd'hui
au gouvernement pourrait pas vous
reprocher cette fidélité alors que
veulent faire oublier ces années
mitterrand je pense pas qu'elle soit
leur problème d'ailleurs si vous me
demandez de mes amis au gouvernement en
tout cas personnellement je ne
changerait pas d'un iota la la fidélité
à une personne
j'ai respecté et que je respecte et que
j'ai aidé mais je la maintiens plus
forte que jamais dire que c'est une
question aussi je dirais de d'éthique de
vie pas beaucoup ce mot mais je
considère que la fidélité à quelques
idées ou à quelques personnes avec qui
on a partagé des moments heureux ou
malheureux fait la noblesse de la vie si
on si tout cela est cassée qu'est ce qui
reste de la vie et du mas vous êtes
fidèle à dumas aussi à roland dumas
voulait seulement faire une galerie de
portraits portrait vous vous êtes le
seul aujourd'hui qui dit enfin des rares
qui dit dumas doit pas démissionner jeu
trop long à expliquer à 16h06 il est
minuit quoi quelle heure est-il 11h30
minuit je me défile pas d'accord non
mais comment soit christine
deviers-joncour après ça aurait été
sympa de savoir si vous étiez fidèles
vous à dumas parce que lui il est plus
tellement fidèle elle enfin bon c'est
pas grave vous voulez vous qu'on en
parle oui c'est pas gai c'est pas une
question de fidélité dans ce cas précis
c'est une question de principe par
rapport à l'idée que je me fais de la
séparation des pouvoirs
il ya des juges d'un côté et elle est
juge de l'autre j'estime que tant qu une
personne connue ou inconnue n'a pas été
mises en cause de façon prouvé certaines
il doit être considéré on l'a proclamé
il ya deux siècles que l'innocent et ça
vaut en particulier pour des gens qu'on
ne connaît pas qui tous les jours encore
malheureusement trop souvent sont
victimes d'arbitraire multiples de
l'administration ou de ou d'abus
policiers ou ou judiciaire très bien
vous est expliqué on est sympa prix ça
va a pris une heure et c'est clair mais
personne n'a dormi il n'y a pas de
mauvais endroit pour s'expliquer croyait
manque un peu de techno derrière ça
aurait été mieux bon alors on va on
recommence on continue sur vos idées
politiques qui nous concerne nous les
jeunes quoique est alors alors le
cannabis le cannabis 30,6 au tandem vous
n'êtes pas toujours de la légalisation
de la dépénalisation
je suis partisan qu'on change la loi à
comment je ne sais pas au juste vous
dire par là qu'il n'y a aucune raison de
désigner une le cannabis comme le la
noce le seul système de d'un de drogue
qu'ils soient pénalisés à ce point
pourquoi pas l'alcool pourquoi pas la
cigarette pourquoi pas d'autres choses
voilà j'estime que l'indélicat claude
vous pouvez sortir le pétard il est
d'accord
sabina rossa
oui bien sûr
cette bourde la légalisation du non mais
moi c'est moi je n'ai jamais fumé des
joints de ma vie j'ai pas entendu que la
vérité c'est savoir c'est rare non mais
je suis honnête j'ai jamais fumé des
joints par contre je suis d'accord parce
qu'en fait ça change rien c'est vrai que
c'est pas plus grave qu autre chose et
que le fait d'interdire ces idiots ça
change rien qu'on moi je suis pas pour
que les gens fument des joints mais je
m'en fiche quoi je comprends vous
entendez bien avec laurent gerra moi
même un peu réac laurent non il est sain
c'est d'arriver un peu réac laurent
c'est pas une insulte à gérer axa veut
rien dire oui enfin ça veut dire réagir
à des shows et vous a déjà emmené chez
ses parents à bourg-en-bresse
ouais et alors c'est bien très bien
merci jack donc maintenant on va passer
à notre débat qu'est ce qui vous fait
haïr et particulièrement qu'est ce qui
fait à jack lang
donc on continue notre côté notre
mission avec avant d'arriver avant
d'arriver à notre débat avant d'arriver
à notre débat sur les victimes durée est
sûre les victimes des médias
on va d'abord regarder un petit peu
l'évolution du rire ces dernières années
avec les méchants avec les absurdes et
avec ce qu'on appelle les naïfs
parce qu'on va être sympa on va regarder
on va on va regarder maintenant les
méchants évidemment il y en a qui nous a
quand il est arrivé qu'ils étaient très
très violent évidemment c'est coluche en
aveugle qui est au bord de la rue quoi
il veut traverser à lorient mais qui
vient il dit à la veille du football
danois le chien là ça fait trois fois
que le feu passe au rouge il vous fait
pas traverser à 10 à l'aveuglé dit vous
faites bien de me le dire
il sent un sucre et il donne aux chiens
alors le mec qui dit mais attends je
comprends pas il vous fait pas traversé
le chien pee wee donner un sucre ils
n'ont baissé pour repérer la tête après
je suis botté le cul
quelques personnes sont très embêtés
avec l'histoire de raciste parce que
vous le savez il peut y avoir des arabes
et des juifs qui se marie enfin place à
même d enfant un garçon demande à son
père papa est-ce que je suis arabe ou
juif son père lui dit tu es l'érable
monfils puisque je suis ton père est tué
mon fils et que je suis arabe
bon il demande à sa mère maman est-ce
que je suis juif et bien sûr tu es juif
puisque je suis ta mère que je suis
juive et pourquoi tu nous demandes ça
mais c'est parce qu'il ya une mobylette
ambages voulait savoir si je la
marchande ou si je la vole
[Applaudissements]
comme ça c'est violent parce que c'est
rare qu'on dise des trucs comme ça dans
des sketches je crois à l'époque j'avais
moins de percussion aujourd'hui encore
mais on a tellement entendu non plus ça
dépend de ce qu'il dit et ça dépend
quelle est la race des liens dont on
note le pitch est connu il ya toujours
en effet raison d'une tendresse qui est
qui et qui est là qui fait que même s'il
est dur mais une part de tendresse
ces femmes ça vous a choqué quand
coluche est arrivé avec ce genre de truc
non jeu un peu jeune j'aime bien cette
émission parce que moi j'ai une façon de
faire qui est bassin taxe est la
suivante un sujet un verbe et un
complément en général je lai et
maintenant je cire les pompes sans les
les chaînés cracher dessus viendra vous
mais je vais vous dire je ne manquerai
pas fait vrai que ce genre de plus ouais
je me dis qu'il ya quand même des gens
qui prennent ça au premier degré et ça
ça m'effraie de me dire après que ces
gens manquent d'humour alors ils disent
ah bah oui on va le raconter puis dans
un dîner en ville ça fait un bon mot
mais ça se fait sur le dos des arabes et
des juifs
voilà c'est que si on commence à voir ce
type de raisonnement l'après c'est
impossible de faire de l'humour connaît
rien faire françois je pense
qu'effectivement tout ce qui est dit
peut être pris un degré ou un autre je
sais par exemple que votre émission
beaucoup de gens la regardent et la
prenne au second degré
c'est fou bon on continue alors on
continue avec les nuls avec le avec le
gipn
chantal une révolte effectivement à la
elle a 25 ans et depuis l'âge de 14 ans
la viole une main droite vient de porter
plainte contre une [ __ ]
hugues aufray a été violée par quinze
hommes dans un club gay à paris dans le
7e arrondissement ignorons tout
l'endroit il a sorti sa guitare au
milieu de la soirée pour entonner
santiano les 15 violeurs ont tous
déclaré avoir compris
debout les gars réveillez vous il va
falloir m'en mettre un coup encore un
fait divers berck-plage le baigneur
imprudent sauvé de la noyade il y a deux
ans par un crs qui lui avait fait le
bouche à bouche vient de mourir du sida
le crs était séropositif oui nous savons
très bien que le sida ne s'attrape pas
par la salive mais le crs avait profité
du coma de la victime pour l'enculé avec
frénésie
[Applaudissements]
hier la première s'était dit désolé
jack lang les nuls par exemple cesser ce
genre de vannes avec hugues aufray tout
ça c'est non mais ne me dites pas que
vous trouvez ça bien parce que très mal
mais très bas mais à partir du moment où
on est introduite en une culturellement
du politiquement correct c'est râpé moi
j'ai terminé il ya plus d'humour
possible il ya plus de liberté possible
donc vous êtes contre le politiquement
correct je parie sur l'intelligence ou
sur l'intelligence et sur le des gens
avec moi me pose toujours la question
est ce qu'on peut rire de tout et on ne
peut rire que de tout à fait rire que
des situations les gens répondent oui
mais ça n'est pas avec tout le monde
mais vous vous répondez autre chose je
peux moi je dis qu'on nous pourrir que
des situations limites ya que c'est une
impasse legault nord etc
les gens normaux continue toujours dans
les dents les méchants donc après
coluche après les nuls
patrick timsit quitté très violent égard
et à des transfusions sanguines
alors lui quand il va arriver au paradis
passera par l'entrée des fournisseurs
il va se sentir chez lui là bas il
connaît du monde salue les et 9 filles
chavagne d'enfants cette dernière
arrivée qui ferme la porte et c'est lui
qui a la clé
on nous a longtemps freiné par que
c'était les homosexuels qui transmettait
le sida aujourd'hui on sait que c'est
les [ __ ] mais les vrais
quatrième c'est un sujet un sujet
d'actualité alors on estime que cela
soit mal pris par un transfuge par
exemple tout à coup il est obligé de
refaire le même sketch devant un
tribunal
ça devient très compliqué à dire c'est
vrai que dans le petit extrait de notre
métier mais s'il convient de voir ce qui
me frappe c'est moins la méchanceté
qu'une certaine forme de démagogie je
suis pas sûr qu'il soit très très
renseigné sur le dossier du sang
contaminé et puis bal en salle à la
vindicte et on a des applaudissements
donc il est né voilà vous avez continué
avec moustiques justement quels sont
votre plateau si allen internationale
s'ouvre à la différence puisque le poste
de directeur de l'information vient
d'être confiée à une personne sourde et
muette en direct de la rédaction du
signal center j'appelle michael cole
michael elie je vais devoir je suis aux
côtés de corinne d'harcourt qui succède
à robert nador en tant que directrice de
l'information de notre chaîne madame
bonsoir alors la question que tous nos
téléspectateurs pour exposer c'est
comment fait-on pour arriver à un tel
niveau de responsabilité malgré son
handicap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour certains de nos journalistes
nous allons répondre aux enfants qui
nous écrivent avides de savoir comment
fabrique-t-on l'avion dash et qu'on
mange à la cantine
et oui la curiosité toujours fini ce que
nous vous proposons aujourd'hui est un
vrai bonheur à l'état pur
ce coffret en ronce de noyer qui ravira
vos invités confirmés plus ni moins que
le rêve absolu
ce coffret nous n'avons appelé le
boîtier bonheur lady di dans son
intérieur en cuir et alcantara
vous découvrirez des objets certains
solide mais tellement chargée d'émotion
et de symboles tels une photo du pont de
l'alma de jour et de nuit un bout de
béton authentifié par le commissaire
louis marc un disque d'elton john
dédicacé et un porte-clés mercedes
si vous commandez dès maintenant le
boîtier bonheur les guider il vous sera
livré dans les plus brefs délais mais
pas trop vite quand même je reviens à ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure la vraie
question c'est nous ça nous fait
énormément rire ses fans ne suis pas sur
scène ça aille ils arrivent ils arrivent
pas s'il n'avait pas pris la même tonne
quand j'ai vu la fille de 6 ans
mais sur les débats son bureau ovale on
peut se moquer des sourds muets les pas
de lady di bari c'est ça aussi
alors c'est vrai que j'ai toujours une
première réaction un peu épidermique est
très émotionnel qui veut dire mon geste
je suis un peu comme jack lang que
j'aime les gens et j'aime et j'ai envie
de le défendre alors mais après il faut
prendre un peu de recul sur soi même et
sur sur ce qu'on se compensent et de se
dire mais sans liberté de blâmer il
n'est pas d'éloge flatteur me reprendre
la phrase de figaro
mais l'asvel exergue à la une du figaro
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut vous vous
avez raison de deux de rire et puis
c'est vrai que c'est à dire que ce n'
est freinée delà de la surinformation
quoi finalement parce que c'est une
femme c'est une maman elle a deux
enfants qui se tournera tunnel c'est pas
marrant du tout mais le fait d'avoir été
médiatisés comme son bref conflit avec
ce truc a donc commis avant par par part
je sais pas où j'en ai été pris à partie
par des gens qui me disaient avoué c'est
un attentat on la tue etc j'avais beau
expliquer confiance ajuster votre pays
mais attendez il ya eu des fantasmes
6/20 sinon d'anciens détenus incroyable
en effet là où je comprends qu'une
partie de votre travail qui est de faire
rire c'est qu'on est dans un contexte
d'hystérie collective
alors c'est vrai que ça mérite temps en
temps un peu de recul je serais mort
sous le pont de sous le tunnel pour de
l'allemagne ça aurait fait trois lignes
ah non
stéphane bohli si ça permettait si cette
prise de conscience a permis à des gens
de faire un peu plus attention en
passant sous le tunnel du pont de l'alma
moi je vous trouve alors moi je vous
trouve pas moins fidèle à la mémoire de
lady day que jacques lang la mémoire de
mitterrand vous devriez être plus là le
sujet n'est pas le même il faut dire
vous avez fait une bêtise quand quand
stéphane bern a écrit son livre sur lady
di il a dit je vais donner l'argent à la
fondation we et mon éditeur a fait
faillite merci stéphane la dernière
phrase que le garde du corps a prononcé
au chaud fort c'est quoi
de winne qui sert forcément alors je
voudrais avant avant d'enchaîner que la
casse est évidemment est en vente libre
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de souci pour
tous les acheter oui légal enfin il
avait bien plein de trucs de dépénaliser
absolument alors on continue avec
françois rollin ici présent le
professeur en lin beaucoup d'entre vous
se plaignent d'éprouver de temps à autre
les angoisses de mort ce genre d'angoise
est parfaitement rationnel pour ne pas
dire absurde et voici pourquoi
pour qu'il puisse y avoir angoisse il
faut qu'il y ait une conscience savon de
marseille par exemple n'a pas d'angoissé
pour la bonne raison qu'il n'a pas de
conscience quant à vous
tant que vous avez conscience de quelque
chose c'est que vous n'êtes pas mort il
n'y a donc pas lieu de s'angoisser
al'inverse dès lors que vous êtes mort
vous n'avez pas plus de conscience qu'un
savon de marseille et il n'y a donc pas
moyen de s'angoisser dans tous les cas
l'angoissent de mort est un contresens
et vous le savez je ne supporte pas bien
les contresens un individu qui vient me
voir et qui me dit j'ai d angoisse de
mort je lui réponds mon petit pote je te
chie sur la tête
je te roule dans la vieille bourse de
vaches et goethe inonde tam interminable
jette pipi farid c'est grossier c'est
possible mais au moins ça a un sens
bonsoir voila franchement peut venir à
leur guise
vous placent quant à l'arrêt mais change
ou du casque et dont les absurdes
c'est gênant si on ne place pas du tout
et ouais
en tout cas j'ai toujours une préférence
pour les choses imaginaire inventé qui
ne fasse pas référence à auch eauze
convient de lire dans le journal le
matin
oui c'est vrai que cette petite aventure
qu'on a fait est jean michel ribes ça
c'est vraiment l'occasion de s'en aller
dans des choses ou à certains moments on
se demande si c'est bien sérieux de bons
continue alors mal on termine plus tôt
là dessus avec ce qu'on appelle les
naïfs alors on va voir ça vous fait rire
c'est les chevaliers du fiel magnéto
alors je rappelle le yucca yéti qui vit
et tente donc à 52 francs vous le fait
une seule adresse pour 136 caisse
jeanine ou écrivez directement au tas
est dispo un cadre juridique à leur top
générique je te le dis au noir où est ce
qu'on a trouvé ce magnifique oeil ou cac
ailleurs on ne trouve pas cette tournée
s'est intéressé tôt télé ah ça vous a
pas fait rire ça lasse acquérir
simplement ce que je dis faut vraiment
une gêne à la juridiction
les dieux sont très pressés serait pas
là mais ça fait beaucoup rire michel
drucker par exemple cette sortie du
contexte il en faut pour tous les goûts
cher thierry on va voir laurent ruquier
au spectacle et henry en plus parfois
jack quand vous avez souffert de votre
marionnette aux guignols ou non non on
peut encore garder un petit peu là de la
marionnette de jack lang vignal peut
précisément vos propositions aux lions
là j'adore ta nouvelle coupe de cheveux
merci et pas cher en plus 120 franchi
coiffe demi
que toi jacques les vacances ça s'est
bien passé formidable tard au chu ma
carte postale celle avec les chatons
parfaitement chalet reçues et toi tu as
eu beau temps un peu plus aurait vu et
du soleil et maintenant je crois qu'il
vaut mieux s'en aller sinon ça va finir
par se voir
on est partis au plaisir à toucher alors
désolé parce que d'habitude chaque fois
qu'on se voit vous avez toujours votre
chemise en vichy bleu et blanc là on n'a
pas droit de changer c'est bien donc ça
ça vous ça vous attend vous embêtez pas
de voir ça non puisqu'on non ce qui n'a
jusque ce qui m'a vue sur les autres
naturellement les gens réagissent
comment j'ai hâte à ce que ppda lui dit
on a le droit de se révolter devant des
allusions purement privé alors qu'il
passe son temps à écrire des livres sur
sur sa famille vous avez beaucoup de
réactions beaucoup de dunes cette fois
ça m'est arrivé sur une petite anecdote
on avait fait une blague sur yves
montand et il avait il avait il avait
appelé je décroche un local au foot j'y
arrive à limiter un peu un peu faut pas
faire des blagues il faut pas faire les
bras comme ça rassure sur ma famille et
tous les mois je vais vous dire je vais
vous cacher la mâchoire et moi j'étais
persuadé que c'était yves lecoq l'orangé
et j'étais là non bâti alors vous
stéphane bern mais je trouve qu'ils
limitent pas mal mais il me fait dans
l'état où il est actuellement
stéphane bernard vous êtes la nouvelle
star des guignols c'est à dire qu'on ne
voit plus que vous c'est très drôle
qu'avant
oui regarde pas beaucoup alors alors
bah vous raconter on va regarder les
têtes couronnées les rois les reines et
il y en a presque plus on a fait le tour
si tu veux ton émission dure stéphane il
faut que tu flottes d'autres gens des
ducs des barons des cons non pas des
nobles des vedettes des starlettes des
gens connus juste mais ce sont des
roturiers je ne peux pas ces salles on
va quand même pas déterrer lady di alors
merde rien n'est pas non mais tout le
monde dit ça mais bon non mais je vous
dire mais c'est très honnête il m'est
arrivé de la voir de temps en temps deux
choses que j'aimerais c'est vrai qu'on
me présente comme le toutou des rois
celui qui s'accroche aux jambes qui
cirent les pompes le valais quoi en gros
leva le valais comme j'ai dis moi ici
j'aime pas cracher sur les gens et pour
cyril pas besoin de lécher alors je ne
les juge pas les pompes par le chien sur
le porta mais d'autres ben j'ai beaucoup
d'autodérision c'est très embêtant ça ne
fait et c'est vrai que ça me fait rire
et puis ça il ya moins de gens qui
passent aux guignols que des gens qui
sont légion d'honneur
donc je me dis que finalement c'est plus
flatteurs nova sauf que quand vous
rencontrez une dame dans la rue auxquels
vous dis à ce qu'il vous faut c'est
terrible pour les établis en justice
plein de gens rient g2g deux cahiers à
la fois les gens dans la rue qui me
disent vous devriez pas vous laisser
faire c'est une honte qui vous font je
dis merci madame c'est gentil alors moi
même je vous dis moi tout ça m'atteint
pas purgé ma nièce elle est adorable
elle a 8 ans et elle me dit je t'ai vu à
la télé c'est à brandt à regarder la
télé ta mère ta laisser regarder 20h30
22h30 selon les émissions et me dit ah
ben non je t'ai vu avant le journal de
20h aux guignols y est calé
ce centre de gens qui disent ravagé un
chien comme vous impossible
paul biya tous les gens justement qui
sont pas contents parce qu'on se moque
d'eux parce qu'ils ont leurs
marionnettes etc
restez chez vous ça fera un bien fou à
tout le monde vous restez chez vous ne
passez pas parce que tu es venu autour
de ce plateau des gens qui se
plaignaient de leurs marionnettes
il est même au contraire c'est comme aux
où il ya des gens qui demandent à être
entré dans deux plaintes
merci merci à tous merci jack lang
d'avoir été notre le transit et merci
beaucoup
et donc on votera pour vous et
européennes
[Applaudissements]
pas moi donc on continue maintenant avec
un sujet à plus grave c'est dire
qu'après les victimes durée on passe aux
victimes des médias et j'accueille
christine deviers joncour
[Musique]
je vais maintenant accueillir christine
deviers joncour mais avant de
l'accueillir on va s'allumer notre le
fameux tube dance et d'une autre amie je
pense qu'on peut le dire au revoir au
revoir
bravo alors j'appelle maintenant la can
atlan christine deviers-joncour bonsoir
christine françois en faire une hyper
new vous allez voir c'est non mais c'est
rien du tout en fait c'est inviter
gestion la banalité et je ne suis pas
tellement gay on a lu cette semaine de
faire arriver avec le sourire des heures
on a lu cette semaine l'article du
parisien on en vous entendu sur rtl vous
entendu sur europe et donc on a eu envie
de vous avoir est de vous poser toutes
les questions qui se posent à votre
sujet voilà alors tout à l'heure en vous
présentant moi j'ai dit christine
deviers-joncour mon camarade ruquier qui
n'en rate pas une a dit la [ __ ] de la
république ce qu'il faut dire quand même
c'est que c'est le titre des adhérents
mais c'est l'équipe de mon livre c'est
le titre du livre enfin c'est un cetain
un surnom qui vous a été donné c'est pas
vous qui voulez oui j'entends beaucoup
de gens dire que je me suis baptisée
comme ça en fait non je crois que si on
lit la quatrième de couverture on
comprend vite gré que si je ne suis pas
baptisé comme ça j'ai écrit ce livre
pour montrer que je ne suis pas là
wilton la république on a baptisé comme
ça et je lui ai appris en sortant déjà
fait parce que pourquoi j'ai accepté que
le livre porte ce titre aussi mais parce
que je crois que j'ai tous les courages
c'est que je crois que je voulais
justement montré que c'était tellement
trop comme ça qu'à travers ce que j'ai
écrit je voulais prouver que j'étais pas
cette femme voilà alors roland dumas
vous appeler ma petite mata hari on
pourrait aussi vous appelez la mata hari
du périgord et ouais mais c'est plus
sympa la maternité
moi j'avoue que ça m'a fait drôle parce
que des parties ardisson m'a dit tiens
il faut absolument que tu lises le
bouquin de dumas j'ai cru que c'était
des trois mousquetaires et en fait
c'était le comte de monte cristo
[Applaudissements]
alors votre histoire ça peut aussi
s'appeler trois hommes et une femme
parce que quand on regarde un peu votre
votre vie finalement comme quand on lit
ce bouquin donc la [ __ ] la république
chez calmann lévy on pourrait
effectivement appelé c'est à trois
hommes trois hommes une femme si elle
n'est pas peu dire sans être vous n'êtes
pas eu de chance avec les mecs quoi eux
non mais c'est vrai vous avez comment
vous êtes fille unique de deux
instituteurs à 10 ans je raconte votre
vie comme ça vous m'arrêtez mais je veux
pas être londres à 17 ans vous préparer
le baccalauréat au lycée la boétie à
sarlat et puis dans la même ville il ya
un garçon qui s'appelle jean jacques de
peretti qui depuis a fait une très belle
carrière et qui était ministre de
monsieur juppé et lui ses parents sont
au maroc ils l'ont envoyée à sarlat il
est très ambitieux il vous dit un jour
je serai maire de sarlat il ce qui était
arrivé yade aurait là de quoi les traits
mais voilà il monte cyrano et c'est
hélas drame alors maintenant je sais que
ça pour les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ça
paraît absolument incroyable enfin on a
le même âge donc tout on a connu cette
époque c'est vrai que quand une fille se
retrouver enceinte est très difficile
voilà et donc vous êtes retrouvée
enceinte
oui mais je le regrette pas aujourd'hui
j'ai un fils merveilleux frédéric qui
est très très beau absolument et donc
bah voilà vous êtes mariés vous êtes
mariés alors que peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui les moeurs ayant évolué
vous seriez fait avorter
oui bah tant mieux finalement donc tu
ravi d'avoir eu sept enfants
voilà donc mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
il était hors de question de c'était la
galère à l'époque c'étaient des
aiguilles à tricoter sur l'étape de
qualifié d' absolument oui c'est moi une
loi que simone veil dont on parlait tout
à l'heure a justement fait voilà alors
donc vous vous mariez avec jean jacques
de peretti parce que vous êtes enceinte
vous avez frédéric et la l'engrenage
commence parce que votre vie c'est un
engrenage
mais ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire dans
ma vie c'est que en fait la politique on
n'en faisait pas chez moi mais mes
parents étaient enseignants on n'a
jamais fait de politique et que
finalement si on regarde ce parcours qui
est absolument être
c'est vrai que la politique poursuit
tout le temps les hommes politiques
alors que je les ai pas cherché
ça c'est drôle c'est le destin c'est le
destin c'est comme les rois
il y peut rien il a levé tous les
chose qui me frappe c'est que vous avez
un point commun camilla parker bowles a
c'est que mon dieu vous êtes aussi vous
fait l'unanimité contre vous dans un
pays alors que finalement la pauvre
uniprix elle est aimée par un homme qui
est connu je suis pas d'accord avec vous
je fais pas l'unanimité contre moi c'est
parce qu'on ne connaît pas je vais vous
dire depuis que j'ai écrit ce livre je
suis très étonné mais je reçois des
lettres de l'acteur et je veux le dire
ce soir je vais en profiter les
remercier qui sont extraordinaires et
qui me donne une force vous pouvez pas
imaginer voulait vraiment et si moi je
m'appelle et je continue je continue je
continue à vendre a le temps on aura le
temps après de parler plus à fond des
prêts mais je raconte votre vie parce
que quand on connaît pas voter
voilà exactement donc vous mentez à
paris lui fait sciences po il travaille
un peu dans une agence de mannequins
pour faire du booking vous fait hésiter
oui vous fait des défilés de lingerie au
salon du prêt-à-porter etc
des photos et puis finalement bon vous
passez vos nuits chez castel ou fumer
des pétards enfin à l'époque passé mais
pas les pétards moi j'aime essayer non
non non plus mais j'aurais peut-être dû
beaucoup là depuis quelques mois
peut-être que j'aurais dû savourer des
donc votre enfant est envoyé dans le
périgord parce que ni le couple explose
squater que jean jacques de peretti il
est absorbé par son boulot
vous vous êtes absorbée par les cris
d'un enfant quand on fait des études
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile et donc
lui est ce qu'on l'a il est pris par le
démon de la politique qui devient chargé
de missions auprès de messmer à matignon
qui à l'époque était l'été prochain
premier ministre
après donc votre fils frédéric avait des
problèmes de santé l'ont pouvait pas
travailler vous vous retrouvez comme
beaucoup de femmes effectivement ça
parle ça parle aux gens votre histoire
parce que vous retrouvez avec un baume
sur les bras on peut pas travailler
parce qu'il faut s'occuper de lui là
vous rencontrez un dénommé cloud joncour
et vous raccrochez un peu à lui on peut
on peut le dire vous lui demandez de
vous épousez je lui demande pas de
m'épouser mais c'est vrai qu'il est
touché un petit peu par par la situation
et puis tu puiqu'il probablement jeu luc
et bien et puis moi j'ai vu le moyen
d'être épaulé et de pouvoir garder mon
fils auprès de moi qui étais toujours
chez ma mère à l'époque donc de
reprendre mon fils vous marier avec lui
alors c'est un peu compliqué bon parce
que lui c'est pas son fils donc le
week-end il le met devant la porte en
disant il faut plein des gens qui
étaient très occupé puisqu'il commencé à
faire ses premiers pas en politique donc
c'est vrai ça prend du temps alors
j'encours claude jean cours dont votre
second mari il vous présente un jour
alfred sirven donc c'est lui qui joue
pas si je dis pas qu'il a fait
l'entremetteur enfin il était assez
content c'est d'accord pour vous
rencontriez sirven et que vous
travaillez avec lui il faut dire qu'il
sirven alfred sirven dit nous parce que
c'est le seul dans votre bouquin que
j'ai lu deux fois qui finalement s'en
sort un peu c'est vraiment parce que
c'est lui qu'ils ont embrasé dans toute
la salle
certains savent ce qu'ils veulent et
d'électeurs qui m'ont écrit beaucoup en
me disant mais pourquoi vous ne connais
pas davantage sur six revers
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que j'ai pas
pensé moi à cogner sur sirven parce que
pour moi c'est pas un mauvais bougre
ouais je veux dire il s'occupait de sa
famille s'occuper de ses filles
pour moi c'était déjà un bon point pour
qui sait quand même si la cervelle c'est
un type qui dit qui a dit un jour à
christine deviers-joncour dis moi la
seule chose que je sais c'est sage faire
c'est donner dé porter des valises voilà
ccc distribuer des commissions voilà une
autre bien sûr et bien faire c'est un
type il fait partie de ce qu'on appelle
les affairistes y en a beaucoup dans
notre république toujours existé bien
sûr même du temps de la monarchie est là
mieux vaut mieux fermer
bah oui allez bosser pour elf donc
numéro 2 0 voilà très n'avait rencontré
avec votre fiat 500 ça vous en étant
dans une station et c'est son mari qui
lui apprennent qu'ils me la présentez
donc et donc sirven voit tout de suite
la faire puisque vous rencontrer à ce
moment là sont nés en 1987 vous
rencontré roland dumas vous aider roland
dumas a gagné aux élections
jacques de peretti oui oui je suis de
toute façon déjà au départ par ma
naissance mes origines je suis plutôt
socialiste vous savez c'est le pays de
jacquou le croquant
donc j'avais bon la femme un peu surtout
la mère abandonnée
et c'est vrai que quand roland dumas est
venu se présenter en dordogne
c'est vrai que ma mère mon père l'ont
aidé dans ses campagnes s'implanter dans
la circonscription et c'est vrai que
j'ai vu un moyen bon ça c'est un petit
truc
oui donc je ne veux pas déranger je dis
je me suis dit si roland dumas gagnent
contre peretti symptômes a certes un peu
vous avez aidé dumas il a gagné
d'ailleurs et sirven voyant ça se dit la
bonne affaire il se frotte les mains et
il se dit je vais envoyer christine
deviers-joncour au contact de dumas et
alors là effectivement là c'est le
pactole
on peut se dire quand on lit ça qui
aurait refusé vous appelez ça un
impacteur louis parce que ça fait c'est
la distribution des caramels non la
distribution des caramels à tout le
monde c'est pourquoi pas moi si moi j'ai
touché tuer la bomba il faut aussi faire
aboutir une grande décidé d'une petite
ville si on a les noms et donc sirven on
peut dire vous accroche au pognon quoi
parce que c'est un peu comme une doigt
quand on en a pas beaucoup et puis d'un
coup on se retrouve avec beaucoup
d'argent c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'avec certains vont perdre
un peu les pédales
ouais un peu les sondés parce que je me
souviens au début bon moi j'avais jamais
beaucoup d'argent je vivais avec claude
jean court j'avais comme toute femme qui
vit à la maison j'étais une femme au
foyer j'avais une somme à gérer pour
mener la maison d'un seul coup vous
tombez dans le circuit d'alpha tire là
etc
je me souviens quand ils me parlaient de
somme des affaires qui brassent r30 à
gauche je me souviens prendre un pas que
je prenais un papier je rajouter les
deux héros et je refaisais 3 3 on
comprend parce que je m'y perds des
commissions dont j'apprends quoi oui oui
vous savez plus où il était on y avoir
du mal à nous mais on a peine à
comprendre les étapes ribot font donc on
peut dire à ce moment là vous êtes
engagé chez elf alors vous aviez onze
mille francs de salaires payés en france
officiellement 40 milles qui était payée
par elle s'acquitte à l'international à
genève et on peut dire un peu vous faire
vous dites dans votre bouquin vous avez
un peu vendu votre âme au diable ce
moment là quoi oui mais je le savais pas
que je vendais mon âme au diable
si aujourd'hui qu'on me dit que j'ai
fait mais je faisais un travail en lien
je faisais mon travail et j'avais
l'impression de bien le faire je dis
aujourd'hui on a noirci même ce travail
que je faisais en le noir si on dit mais
elle a manipulé
ministre l'attendait quand j'essayais de
ne pas manipuler mais quand j'essayais
de convaincre le ministre de signer des
contrats importants pour haifa qui tête
ont pas d d assigner des contraintes
pourtant en faisant descendre le
président de la république à tel endroit
où on négocie en d'une façon non c'était
bon pour la france plus en période de
chômage
il me le disait chez elf il me dit faut
y aller c'est des contrats je tiens mes
avocats mise et vous allez vous auriez
dû être décoré pour toutes admises à
fleury mérogis mais je crois que c'est
vrai géant pourquoi on ainsi mon travail
aujourd'hui pour enfoncer roland dumas
ce qu'il faut dire aussi qu'il peut lire
aussi facile effectivement c'est que
elle sape a été créée par roland dumas
ni par personne c'est des grès par de
gaulle en 58 attendez que je les
affaires elf aquitaine quand on dit
aujourd'hui dans le journaux el foul
affaire elf aquitaine de pointe
christine deviers-joncour attendait mais
moi je moi j'en peux plus là enfin il
affaire elf aquitaine à des barres en
1958 à l'arrivée du général de gaulle
elle a été elle a été créée par l'état
pour l'état en fait c'est une annexe
oui ça sert de caisse noire à l'état
depuis toujours la faire il faut
commencer à 1958 mais joue pas il faut
pas la faire démarrer à crécy nous
visons pour attendez moi continuer si on
continue l'histoire mais c'est bien de
le préciser donc là effectivement vous
avez un train de vie l'appartement rue
de lille
placido domingo qui vient chanter
pavarotti qui viendrait vous c'était
bien avant que domingo c'est déjà pas
mal
un très beau pierre fenard soir est donc
là c'est effectivement vous vous êtes
payés par elf pour organiser les
relations publiques de m
donc effectivement poussé dumas certains
insignes et certains contrats ou à
s'intéresser à certaines à certaines
affaires d'ailleurs vous faites ça très
gentiment sûr que vous dites dans votre
bouquin vous laisser les hommes
parlaient et vous vous êtes un petit peu
comme ça avec les femmes un peu on
cuisine vous attendez que l'édile se
fasse quoi donc vraiment au service de
cette affaire oui c'est sûr service mais
on ne l'a pas caché le début j'étais là
pour les aider j'employais j'étais là
aussi pour organiser des dîners dans
l'appartement que f mais avait mis à
madisson robert estienne
au début c'est vrai que ce que je
faisais c'était pas juste une
entremetteuse
la république à l'heure où nous autres
africains on nous mettait un contrôle
des changes incarner des changes inquiet
oui un carnet de change pour traverser
les frontières
ça vous choque pas d'avoir un compte en
suisse vous savez monsieur vous avez un
patron chez elf rentrer chez moi je sais
même pas ce que c'était des cantons de
suisse à l'époque on vous propose un
salaire payé de 1,9 en france et on vous
dit bon c'est pas assez parce que tu
travailles beaucoup donc on va tendre
vers ca en suisse ah bon vous le refusez
à la télévision devant les caméras oui
bon alors là vous raconter d'ailleurs
vous raconter ça dans le papier de
valdiguié du parisien je voulais
raconter cette semaine là alors il ya
des images absolument extraordinaire
c'est sirven qui fait un alfred sur 20
qui fait sa tournée
alors il a une voiture et puis dans le
coffre de voiture y ait de couverture
puis sous la couverture et des billets
de tous les billets de 500 et des
liasses de billets de 500 et il
distribue quoi il dit c'est comme le
laitier sauf qu'au lieu de livrer du
lait ils vivent des billets de 500 et
alors vous ne dites pas évidemment
aujourd'hui vous n'avez citer personne
vous dit qu'il ya deux anciens ministres
il ya un premier ministre de gauche donc
la commande est là depuis son lapsus
fois plus je dis dans mon livre alfred
cervin donnez donnez toujours des trams
mais ne donnait jamais des détails trop
prudent ouais ils avaient des tiroirs
ils avaient des codes des choses comme
ça donc c'est un peu les choses que je
ne suis pas complètement idiote
j'ai entendu des choses je voyais bien
qu'il se passait des choses et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je je sors un peu
de mes gonds parce que parce que d'abord
je sais que plein de gens fait quand il
ya quand même quelques quelques semaines
que mon patron elle fait qu'elle ferait
de sir20 n'ait pas été recherchée par la
justice
jusqu'à présent on a mis en prison j'ai
subi tout ce que j'ai subi et je le
connais très fort donc j'apprends ça
après c'est vrai que c'est vrai que cet
acharnement de toute cette pression
médiatique sans arrêt avec l'affairé elf
racing de vision pour la période
c'est vrai que là maintenant j'en peux
plus en plus là maintenant on me prend
les
on fait des scellés sur des gardes même
parce que je déménage pas dire qu'on met
ses les scellés sur des affaires de
bénéfices ces cadeaux de mariage non
mais attendez je crois que là c'est vrai
ça non mais je peux les chips et
invisible christine c'est clair de
lampistes comme on dit là surtout vous
avez quand même il ya quand même eu dans
cette affaire quatre milliards de francs
distribués à 300 personnes qui ont
touché 4 milliards de francs
alors on sait a paru dans la presse
c'est pas nous qui le dévoile ce soir
non je veux dire ça il faut qu'on en
parle il faut que la justice fasse son
travail
il ya eu 44 aussi personnes qui ont
touché à leur vraiment des salaires
fictifs dans mon dossier qui sont tombés
la presse en a parlé je dévoile pas le
secret de l'instruction
donc cela on n'en parle plus je dire
cela ils n'ont pas été mis en examen ils
n'ont pas été mises en détention pour
isa je vais dire moi ça suffit c'est
parce que je suis une femme alors il
faut que je prenne
je veux pas je vais pas pleurer sur mais
là vous rires non non vous un normal
bien entendu donc parallèlement à ce
travail donc de relations publiques pour
elle
vous tombez enfin je sais pas si vous
tombez amoureux c'est pas moi d'en
parler mais pas aux vignes love story
etc roland dumas qui est un peu votre
pygmalion mais ça on comprend très bien
c'est un type formidable très cultivé
qui aime la vie qui affecte revenus une
instruction
c'est vrai on s'en va et c'est vrai oui
moi vous avez restauré qui est de 100
j'avais deux sens du terme absolu dans
les descentes
vous avez droit à des chargements s'est
passé absolument donc ils quittent quand
même pas sa femme pour vous mais vous
connaissez beaucoup de politiques qui te
donnes tout court c'est vrai que ça fait
qu'on sache enfin que c'était quand même
difficile parce que j'avais jamais connu
ces milieux là j'avais 40 ans j'avais
dans les deux perles qui avait si
j'avais mes défis je travaille comme ça
non mais je l'avais le bac japonais mais
aujourd'hui je me dirais mais tu as été
une façade était gosse et qu'ils mangent
et enfants toutes les affaires le cigare
c'est pas vous non
il ya eu il ya eu il ya eu un des
moments d'ambiguïté dans notre relation
gens dans votre relation avec jumaa il y
avait des moments d'ambiguïté parce que
c'est vrai que bon j'étais sur mon
amoureux l'un de l'autre enfant puis des
photos dans match qu'on a vue ou qui
prouve cette relation qui parlent
d'elles-mêmes absolument vous vous êtes
bien être tous les deux sous ça fait
c'est agréable surtout de les voir sur
le sable oui et là et vous et vous vous
demandez vous vous demandiez il vous dit
temps en temps est ce que vous êtes là
pour moi ou pour elf aquitaine cire que
c'est quand même une relation ambiguë en
même temps parce que lui c'est bien vous
savez que c'est et c'est un travail
quand même c'était c'est vrai que je
suis ton même pas moi il m'a peut-être
qu'il aurait mieux valu peut-être que ça
ne devrait pas amener là où ça ne
s'était plus facile en sachant et tout
le monde savait que j'étais que j'étais
la mairie de roland dumas et c'est vrai
que tout était mélangé le travail un
moment donné tous ces croisés et c'est
vrai que roland dumas et est un homme
qui comme beaucoup d'hommes il faut
quand une femme est amoureuse sont elles
s'accrochent
souvent elle en veut davantage et ce
genre d'homme il faut surtout pas donc
c'est vrai que moi j'avais une chance
extraordinaire et je travaille est de
plus en plus pour elf aquitaine quand
elle me disait il faut aller le voir
merci mon dieu je pouvais aller le voir
ça c'était extraordinaire sur donc mais
sam a gelé paient très cher tout ça
une question pas possible qu'ils en ont
encore une fois en tant que femme je
comparais de cette valeur c'est que vous
dites enfin j'imagine que vous l'aimiez
fait que vous le dis très clairement ça
mais c'est en même temps c'était faire
pression de lui faire faire des choses
cette pression c'est en même temps un
peu de la manipulation aussi commander
on vous arriviez dans votre cette
espagne là non l'intégrité et puis parce
que j'ai c'est vrai de liens scinder les
choses et c'est vrai la maîtrise et
quand j'allais le voir et que
probablement peut-être il en avait assez
de me venir me voir en tant que elf
aquitaine
peut-être qu'il avait envie de deux que
je vienne le voir en tant que christine
xavier vraiment et j'arrivais en tant qu
elle s'est souvent barre des 100
féliciter tous parce que je trouve qu'il
fait la différence entre le passé et le
présent c'est contre c'est que les
hommes sont devenus vachement plus lâche
beaucoup plus là mais avant les rois il
afficher leurs maîtresses et assumer
leur bâtard et aujourd'hui il couche
avec
en dehors du mariage alors réussi à
assumer stéphane christine est l'exemple
même des rangs dit toujours dans l
affaire elf dans la sphère elle
mais seuls c'est vrai on est toujours
dans la sphère est le seul bonnes âmes
c'est qu'ici les gens on m'a dit ça
récemment le c'est vrai mais qui paraît
qu'il y avait un homme dont l aquitaine
c'était moi c'est une des choses sur
lesquelles on s'est focalisé rien sur
lesquels la presse s'est focalisée il ya
effectivement vous est aussi l'histoire
des chaussures oui fameux super de
chaussures à onze mille francs oui c'est
vrai que ça impressionne les gens une
paire de chaussures à onze mille francs
marché avec un smic à chaque pied c'est
énorme mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais j'ai encore ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que rien entendre à une infirmité
c'est vrai que ce sont les chaussures
cher mais c'est vrai que soient pas de
la simple coquetterie
non mais là c'est vrai que je me dis pas
du tout parce que tout le monde mais
violent c'est vrai que roland dumas a
mais peut-être qu'il n'aimerait pas que
je dis ça mais c'est vrai qu'il a un
problème et il a fait une chute de ski à
30 ans il n'a pas voulu se faire opérer
et là un tibia qui s'est soudée comme ça
voilà manque 5 cm et au fil des années
sa et claudique comme talleyrand voilà
et ils souffrent et moi je me souviens
qu'à l'époque la comparaison c'est juste
pour ça non mais j'ai plein de
comparaison mais c'est l'écriture est
venue faire une paire de chaussures
parce qu'elle voulait lui faire plaisir
parce qu'il avait une jambe plus cool
non pas lui faire plaisir je vous ai dit
il faut que vous alliez vous faire faire
des chaussures alors en bas de chez moi
il
il faisait des chaussures sur mesure et
qui a pu lui mettre faire un feu rouge
pas une forme on prendrait fin des âmes
et lui faire exactement le ce qui
manquait pour qui et qui ne souffre plus
voilà et l'aï l'avs commander ses
chaussures
et le jour où il a fallu aller les
chercher en partie partait en voyage
accompagné le voyage officiel les
secrets du secrétariat m'appelle dire le
ministre des ses chaussures il avait des
stations debout à faire et les vues et
les voeux je passais c'était en bas mais
voilà et oui mais la dure depuis quand
on parle du président conseil du conseil
constitutionnel ont dit roland dumas et
ses pairs rien rater
bon on continue alors donc après je vais
vite affaire des frégates parce que ça
on n'est pas là pour raconter la sphère
des frégates vendues à taïwan
vous touchez finalement bon et qui est
ce qu'elles ont été vendus grâce à vous
pas grâce à vous on va pas faire ça il y
avait à l'époque effectivement par
françoise sagan par exemple à et c'est
que ces publics a influé sur le
président mitterrand à l'époque où on
avait trouvé du pétrole en ouzbékistan
tire quand on est près des gens
puissants tout le monde essaye de les
faire changer d'avis et même sur écoute
me les types qui l'ont entendu centre
dépressionnaire d'une chute alors par la
science de décryptage mais dans quelques
années on saura ce qu'elle a et livrer
les lignes françaises dites donc vous
toucher 45 millions vous dites les a
rendus vous avez rendu chez lui
voilà vous dites je les ai rendu et
l'appartement de la rue de lille je suis
parti vous êtes parti bhl donc voilà
aujourd'hui vous vous retrouvez ses cris
voilà un deuxième roman un premier roman
les verser une caution de 1 million de
familles au revoir sortir prison comment
on va pouvoir sortir de prison je suis
sorti de prison et on m'a tout ne m'ont
donné un mois près de moi prendre à
repousser à trois mois et le 10
septembre il fallait que je verse 1
million subban y retourner c'est vrai
que j'avais pas les sous la course
contre la montre alors j'ai écrit ce
livre pour cette raison aussi en même
temps pour pour dire qu'ils jettent et
parce que les médias n'avaient tellement
massacrés et que c'était pas possible de
survivre à ça j'ai bien fait sur le
liffe a sûrement comme un dieu c'est
vrai qu'au départ j'ai écrit ce livre
d'abord pour ça mais après bon c'est
vrai que ça m'a servi à payer la caution
ok puis et puis les anciens quand il
vous est maintenant vous êtes dans le
pétrin mais pas du tout elle a lu des
lettres en prison de gens qui datait des
lettres anonymes elle reconnaissait des
détails qui prouvait que c'était ses
amis d'avant qu'il a balancé sur la
nature humaine c'est une leçon
formidable dans des lettres anonymes qui
sont tombés dans mon dossier
j'ai retrouvé des phrases et je savais
exactement qui pouvait dire ça d
les intimes on avance alors donc vous
allez en prison là effectivement vous
passez directement c'est vrai que c'est
c'est la roche tarpéienne est proche du
capitole parce que c'est vrai que vous
passez de la rue de lille de ce luxe
effectivement à la prison c'est terrible
quoi vous raconter je vais pas le faire
ici parce qu'on n'est pas là pour faire
mireille dumas justement mais vous voilà
à quoi vous raconter c'est vrai que
c'est on va essayer de vous on a essayé
de vous casser pour vous faire parler
pour vous citiez la maison mes avocats
ont dénoncé un chantage médiatique voilà
cet âge c'est tout cas c'est donc
excusez-moi chantage du titien pour me
faire parler j'ai mes avocats m'ont dit
que si j'avais dit des choses sur du
mage n'allait pas prises a entendu et
donc vous résister alors vous vous votre
tension tombe à 6 vous perdez 12 kg on
met votre fils en garde à vue vous
résister à toutes ces humiliations de la
prison ces gens là lumière allumée
les gens qui vous regardent par
l'oeilleton enfin je vais pas vous
raconter ça va ça va vous enlevez votre
sourire bien tenu vous êtes mieux quand
vous seriez comme moi voilà non mais bon
ça c'est dans le bouquin disons que
c'est très pénible à lire et que ça a dû
être effectivement encore beaucoup plus
peiné il ya des tensions toute façon
qu'elles soient provisoires ou pas
provisoire c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'en sortant je m'étais dit je vais me
battre pour ça pour que ça se sache
un pays des droits de l'homme et la
france qui se targue d'être le champion
qu'il ya des choses qu'il faut c'est
honteux de laisser mange pas je peux pas
la situation je suis me battre mais
peut-être qu'un jour je le ferai si je
peux si jamais les moyens
puis vous avez peur en prison de
l'argent il ya deux types qui viennent
on vous dit à deux types qui sont
passées vous dire c'est qu'ils les types
qui sont ces mondiaux repart à nouveau
la porte pour donner la gamelle et et il
ya la madone et puis une codétenue qui
sert et et c'est tout et là je vois deux
messieurs habillé comme vous n'en sent
la cravate là mais un peu comme ça et
d'oublier normalement pas
et puis ils ont regardé comme ça dans la
cellule
j'ai trouvé ça très étrange et come back
au cellulaire plus l'habitude de la
prison que moi elle a été tout de suite
très très inquiète elle m'a dit ça c'est
dangereux
alors on s'est renseigné effectivement
en nous sommes en moi j'ai mis ma petite
enquête les la prison m'a dit que
c'était des gens qui étaient venus faire
le devis d'une cuisine delà des cuisines
de fleury et en fait on a appris après
que la cuisine était en fait depuis deux
ans c'est pas qu'il soit vraiment pour
rénover les 45
c'est vrai que c'est inquiétant bah oui
non mais toute façon c'est clair
aujourd'hui vous savez beaucoup de
choses ce qui vous plonge dans le cas
beaucoup dans le choix je le dis dans
mon livre alfred cervin donner des trams
ne donnez jamais les détails ce que je
dis dans le parisien aujourd'hui je peux
pas en dire davantage je veux dire j'ai
pas j'ai pas allé non j'ai pas assisté
moi de toute façon le fait vous parlez
je sais que ça existe mais d'être
médiatisé vous protège d'une certaine
façon je crois que oui c'est une
question très bête très pragmatique
depuis 16 mois comment vous vivez ça
parce que je le vis très mal mais je le
vis je suis là il faut que je me batte
faut que j'aille jusqu'au beau j'aime
fils qui comptent sur moi et sinon je
serais pas ressorti de fleury mérogis
ouais vous fait penser à vous suicidez
labdaoui plusieurs fois vous êtes un peu
dans la situation de marilyn monroe
ça fait tellement de choses que les cas
mais l'île ont fait supprimer vous savez
ce qui est terrible c'est pas tant la
détention la détention c'est une horreur
mais ce qui est le plus dur je crois
c'est que vous savez on allait en à la
télé on continue et j'en avais la télé
dans la cellule c'est de se voir un beau
jour christine deviers-joncour comme ça
en haut un et vous prenez ça plein fouet
dans huit mètres carrés assis sur votre
paillade
mais c'est pas vrai en fait c'était mon
image qu'on avait piles et en mille
morceaux en reprenait ses morceaux comme
un peu pesé et on était et je me
reconnaissais pas je crois que la
pression médiatique en prison m'a fait
encore plus de mal que la justice ou la
détention
vous voyez ça cet été les parce que vous
êtes là vous pouvez pas parler pour ne
rien dire que vous connais quand prévenu
c'est ce qu'on appelle la wii mais en
prison oui on échange mais bien sûr car
on veut aller parler c'est une prison
c'est une horreur on peut rien faire
puisque vous énerver ses comprenait des
vieux bouts de films j ai pas jean alex
kpatcha l'extrait l'heure de vérité
avec quoi avec mes lunettes noires et
j'avais l'impression d'être je sais pas
à quoi c'est effrayant voyez comment
votre avenir là moi je vois pas d'avenir
manger gère au jour le jour
pour l'instant j'ai pas d'avenir vous
savez j'ai j'ai plus de liberté vous
savez gestion j'ai le droit de sortir de
chez dc j'ai pas le plein de gens que je
dois pas voir jeu bon c'est vrai que je
suis très encadrée donc j'ai pas
beaucoup de liberté
j'en ai une c'est que le jour où j'en
peux plus j'arrête c'est tout c'est la
seule que j'ai et j'en ai une deuxième
c'est à travers un roman que je suis en
train d'écrire mais qui est un roman qui
est une fiction je vais pouvoir parler
un petit peu de choses de caractère des
gens de ça c'est une liberté parce que
là c'est vrai que là c'était christine
deviers joncour oui mais là j'ai envie
de parler d'être un peintre et les
hommes
ben justement je vais parler des hommes
donc merci en tous les cas de votre
franchise et bravo pour votre courage
les élus par la lecture du bouquin
voilà donc on continue on continue sur
le lynchage médiatique sur les victimes
des médias de cuisine vous restez avec
nous volontiers on vous garde et on
accueille djamel bouras et francis
lalanne djamel bouras bonsoir alors vous
aurez l'occasion dans les minutes qui
viennent d'expliquer ce qu'on veut dire
si vous êtes champion du monde de judo
olympique champion olympique de judo
il confond avec la boxe c'est très grave
si bien et on va voir dans l'histoire
vous allez nous raconter l'histoire qui
est arrivé
francis lalanne bonsoir
et gérard miller
comment
otez moi d'un doute c'est le gérard
muller de france inter c'est le gérard
miller qui est tous les jours et coûter
par deux millions deux cent cinquante
mille personnes dans tous les sens où et
qui est victime du médium n'est pas
victime les médias mais il a un avis sur
les médias janadi surtout gérard miller
non ouais je vous écoute toujours mes
parents vous trouve mes chances par des
bêtes méchants du nom bon d'accord
alors on va commencer avec vous francis
lalanne d'abord votre actualité
moi je ne suis pas une victime des
médias donc je jette pas une victime des
médias vous avez quand même je suis pas
là pour ça je suis là pour parler de la
sortie de mon livre et de mon spectacle
au bataclan mais on va en parler en
masse le 12 février on va là on va
commencer dans l'embarras donc je tiens
à dire que en ce qui me concerne je n'ai
je n'ai accusé ni personne d'aucun crime
concernant wii puisque pour moi le monde
médiatique est un monde qui s'exprime et
on connaît sont engagées que partir du
moment où on connaît son langage on
accepte ou alors ouais on ne fait pas ce
métier vous voulez plutôt refusé parce
que vous avez quoi moi clairement oui
c'est 12 heures on peut dire quand même
que vous êtes quelqu'un qui a toujours
eu maille à partir avec vous et quand
mme boxer pas mal vous c'est pas le judo
c'est la boxe vous avez beau que c'est
quand même pas mal de photographes pas
mal de journalistes j'ai toujours été un
peu rebelle par rapport au système
médiatique et vous l'ont fait payer
personne ne m'a rien fait payer et je
n'ai boxé personnes contrairement à ce
qu'on peut lire dans la presse mais dans
tous les articles qui sont dans le
dossier de presse et qui concerne les
bagarres vous avec des reporteurs avec
des gens et ça c'est faux écoutez la
façon dont l'histoire est racontée et
bien entendu fossat et je viens de
raconter la vraie alors je pense pas non
moi je pense que vous avez jeunesse il
faut parce qu'il n'a peut-être jamais
bossé personnel a commencé ce soir mais
ce que tu veux dire c'est que un jour
jean cocteau a dit je suis un mensonge
qui dit toujours la vérité
je crois que c'est un petit peu une
phrase qu'on pourrait appliquer au monde
médiatique le monde médiatique n'est
plus là pour informer les là pour
distraire on le sait est hélas vont va y
suit les tendances qu'ils pensent être
celle des autres celle du spectateur et
qui souvent ne le sont pas d'ailleurs
et quand on pense que
les gens ont besoin de potins on leur
sort du potin quand on pense que les
gens ont besoin des missions culturelles
on leur sert des émissions que toi n'est
en fait les gens ont besoin des choses
très saine
mais comme ils sont très fatigués quand
ils rentrent du travail mais il regarde
ce qu'on leur montre à la télé et puis
prennent ce qu'ils mangent alors ce que
je veux dire c'est quoi ça fait sept ans
par exemple qu'on vous a pas vu on peut
pas dire qu'on leur montre souvent
francis lalanne moi j'ai dû faire à peu
près une dizaine d'une quinzaine de
télévision à 20 ans c'est un choix
personnel
j'ai eu la chance d'arriver dans ce
métier à une époque où le monde
médiatique n'avait pas autant
d'importance et les gens sortaient de
chez eux ils allés à la rencontre des
artistes est un petit peu ce qui est en
train de se passer maintenant grâce à
l'avènement du du rap du tout les
groupes alternatifs qui se produisent
dans des lieux non non subventionnées
enfin non je vais décider d'être
marginal en quelque sorte que ça se
passait mal un génial par rapport à quoi
et par rapport à qui bas par rapport aux
médias
mais alors qu'il était alors moi on
s'est rencontré il ya 15 ans dans une
émission sur tf1 que seraient les scoop
à la une je m'en souviens très bien
m'avait dit c'est le fera le génial m'a
dit quand vous étiez sur scène et que ça
se passait très bien vous jouissiez dans
votre votre si j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit
que j'ai une m'était arrivé de ressentir
un plaisir extrême avant me regardera la
bande à tirer si vous pouviez arrêté
et parce que vous êtes à côté de moi
alors je dis assez conséquent à 15 ans
elle avait retenu que ça de francis
larger pas retenu que ça s'agite ça
dénote un certain état d'esprit on
viendrait pas ça mais j'ai je suis on
est là moi je vous vois persie de
revenir aujourd'hui il est devenu une
fois d'un double jeu non ce que je veux
dire simplement c'est que vous avez été
mis à l'écart des par les gens des
médias atteint personnes ah bon alors
parlons de vos spectacles vous faites
une comédie musicale avec herbert pagani
au bataclan qui s'appelle megalopolis
ouais bah parlons-en c'est quoi eh bien
puisque je suis venu pour ça je vais
donc en parler
cher cher thierry il s'agit donc d'un
spectacle une comédie musicale dans ma
très jeune carrière puisqu'elle n'a que
20 ans je n'avais encore jamais
participé à une comédie musicale et elle
a été mise en scène est adapté de
l'oeuvre d'herbert pagani par un jeune
metteur en scène qui s'appelle bernard
bittan dont j'avais vu un spectacle il
ya quelques années qui m'avait
bouleversé qui s'appelait le sel et le
miel et donc il a adapté l'oeuvre de
pagani la trouver dans les chansons de
pagani des personnages ce qui est
extraordinaire ça raconte quoi alors
megalopolis à raconte une histoire très
contemporaine qu'est qui va vous plaire
je pense thierry vous qui êtes un
publiciste c'est-à-dire un polémiste et
non pas quelqu'un qui fait de la
publicité ça raconte l'histoire d'un
monde consensuel qui sans faire dans le
dans les arrêts dans l'est le marasme de
la pensée unique c'est à dire vous savez
on n'est plus dans un monde totalitaire
aujourd'hui où là le pouvoir s'exerce
par la violence armée
on est dans un monde subliminal où la
violence s'exerce par une dialectique
très simple qui est celle de
l'alternance de la caresse avec une
manipulation médiatique qui tend à
culpabiliser celui qui ne pense pas la
même chose que la majorité met pas
souvent à la télé mais quand vous venez
à la main après sont infinies voilà non
mais c'est bien le seul mot que je veux
dire si vous permettez je me suis
empressé que l'expression de cette vie
intime c'est à dire de la relation
amoureuse qui pratiquent entre eux ou de
la relation d'amitié qui pactisent
pratique entre eux et bien s'est
présenté comme étant finalement
aujourd'hui la réponse au pouvoir
vertical je crois que plus aux villes
intime plus envie d'amitié plus envie
d'amour personnel et plus on rebelles
voilà ce que racontent ces titres est
bien gérard miller ça vous branche
yes je réponds tu n'aimes ici je réponds
oui
non non non le dire non non je trouve
que vous l'avez bien présentés mais je
vous en remerçie vrai bien présent on a
le droit de ne pas adhérer
moi je suis tellement pour la liberté
d'expression que même pour le droit à
l'injurier ouais je préfère qu'un
journaliste 10-15 mensongers qui nous
est pas de dire une vérité je vais pas
justifier ce que je vais dire maintenant
parce que je connais bien la lan d'abord
parce que j'étais ado j'allais le voir
quand il chantait sous les chapiteaux à
l'époque
et puis ils étaient très bons comédiens
aussi dans l'affrontement avec j'aime
bien jouer avec jean piat mais bon
évidemment il ya des défauts on les
connaît les défauts d'alan il s'emporte
facilement est un peu la fin je garde
mon calme vous avez pu remarquer vous
emportez un peu facilement parce que
c'est pas un peu de la provoc quand même
d'appeler ça megalopolis des gâteaux
avec la dame
écoutez moi j'ai déjà écrit tous les
articles mégalo francis mettait un
machin ou bon mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est pas moi qui écris le
titre et megalopolis on va faire un peu
d'étymologie un peu de grecs police et
la ville mégalo vous connaissez la
grande ville c'est un hasard bon et de
toute façon le regard des autres
n'engage que que même et le regard des
autres mais vous savez que vous allez
au-devant des critiques avec ce titre là
il a l'habitude non mais écoutez on
quand on fait ce métier on va au devant
des critiques mais on va au devant de
joie qui sont bien plus immense que les
petits des plaisirs que peuvent nous
causer d'après
je passais souvent à côté du théâtre où
francis lalanne jouer l'affrontement
c'est quelqu'un qui va au devant des
chauffe c'est important c'est quelqu'un
qui écoute et c'est quelqu'un qui alors
je sais pas comment la pièce appelée
l'affrontement moi j'ai jamais vu a fait
commencer pas le flatter parce que vous
connais verne
comment s'est passée pas un prince et 3
sujet un verbe un compliment
est-ce que les miens alors celui qui
s'appelle et ryad où il des halles
épigrammes amoureuse et vous dites que
il faut lire une page juste avant de
faire l'amour à chaque fois oui enfin je
regarde le nombre de pas savoir quand
même jour ses radios elles sont bien
s'il ya cent poèmes non mais c'est un
conseil moi je pense que l'amour l'amour
charnel l'amour charnel a aussi besoin
de mots et je pense que les poètes c'est
leur rôle de donner des maux aux
plaisirs ouï-dire aussi pendant la la ça
dépend de qui on est bien sûr et puis
depuis sept ans vous étiez où j'ai fait
bien des choses là lamont interruption
d'activité de deux chanteurs et dieu
avant tout au fait que j'ai eu un procès
avec une maison de disques donc qui m'a
interdit pendant des années puisqu'il a
duré sept ans cinq ans exactement
m'interdit de d'enregistrer et donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas pu le faire
donc j'ai développé d'autres choses je
développe et la littérature j'ai publié
des livres de poèmes j'en ai j'en ai dit
et d'autre j'ai développé la dramatique
puisque j'ai joué pendant trois ans avec
jean piat de saison à paris une tournée
en province
et puis j'ai gagné mon procès est donc
maintenant ça me permet de pouvoir
prétendre à enregistrer un nouvel album
ce que je suis en train de faire en
français pour moi en espagnol aussi pour
une tournée que je vais faire en
amérique du sud et j'enregistre
également l'album du spectacle
megalopolis qui serait versé aux trois
albums dont générera pour vous qui vous
êtes occupé des petites figurines aussi
alors j'ai également pendant cette
période
relancer une entreprise dans le périgord
qu une région que de vous devez
connaître
je cuisine devient connais bien quitter
l'entreprise
pas encore et ils n'ont pas encore
trouvé chaussure à leur pied
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que non
non je suis beaucoup de respect pour
roland dumas je voulais lui dire voilà
et simplement non ce sont des
c'est une entreprise qui tue votre côté
asocial sa part dont sir que corot lancé
le passage
christine jamais encore là du camp
roland dumas dit le président de la
public peut plus être attaquée est
vraiment aussi chirac peut pas être
embêté sur les hlm de paris
et quand roland dumas pour pas être
emmerdés sur elle fit de n'assurer que
la possibilité de ne pas être attaqué
sur les la mairie de paris les hlm de
paris vous vous n'allez pas me dire
qu'enfin franchement c'est puis je
verrais bien un type comme vous un type
honnête comme vous ou alors puisse vous
répondre non répondent et moi parce que
je serais curieux de connaître votre
réponse reçue moi j'ai vu le dessin du
monde lui serre la main
chirac et d'humains en se disant merci
et que c'est la plus belle une du monde
que j'ai vu depuis longtemps quitté moi
je vais vous dire une chose je n'ai
jamais été en accord avec les thèses du
gouvernement que défendent et roland
dumas
je les ai combattu j'ai payé le prix
pour ça mais jusqu'à preuve du contraire
je crois que l'on peut combattre
quelqu'un en tout cas combattre les
idées de quelqu'un et le respecter bon
alors mis leur faisait quelque chose à
des témoignages je trouve qu'il est rare
d'entendre quelqu'un dire publiquement
qu'il a de la sympathie pour roland
dumas moi j'en ai aussi beaucoup
je suis cependant d'accord avec vous sur
le conseil constitutionnel parce que je
trouve que ça peut vraiment un problème
soupçonné à ce point les décisions du
conseil constitutionnel mais juste sur
la question roland dumas c'est
formidable quand même dans un pays comme
le nôtre à quel point un moment donné on
a le sentiment qu'on ne peut plus dire
du bien de quelqu'un ils ont
immédiatement être soupçonnée du pire
je suis absolument pour que cette
enquête ait jusqu'au bout et d'un autre
côté c'est vrai que je trouve formidable
pour puisse dire qu'on a versé un
bâtiment du vin parce que c'est un type
formidable
s'il a fait des choses que la loi
réprouve et bien qu'il soit puni mais
c'est quand même
alors je vais dire que c'est quelqu'un
qui passe quand même pas si souvent que
ça dans les médias lalanne parce que
dans l'ensemble à l'acheter c'est quand
même un moment donné de se dire oh de
toute façon je vais pas me compromettre
tout le monde tape ce roland dumas je
vais faire pareil très bien ses vues
c'est dit merci djamel bouras alors vous
avez déclaré
l'histoire qui mon histoire qui m'est
arrivé c'est une cycliste djamel bourras
le fameux cycle c'est djamel bouras vous
avez déclaré c'est une histoire à la
omar m'a tuer ce qui m'est arrivé alors
raconté nouveau brièvement comment vous
avez l'histoire comment vous vous l'avez
vécu dix ans ça vient mais apparemment
vous avez un beau sourire bien sûr
malheureusement ouais ce qu'on m'a
toujours appris que l'essentiel c'est de
boire de manger de respirer mais mes
anouma m'a tuer parce que j'ai suivi la
dernière fois son son histoire et et
c'est vraiment en plus quand
j'expliquais un peu ça c'est comme si
comme accusé d'un meurtre
disons aujourd'hui que je me retrouve en
inde ou ouais c'est vraiment et c'est ça
le pire c'est que c'est d'un côté
heureusement qu'on a les médias mais à
cause des médias les gens qui savent que
je suis innocent n'ont pas voulu
m'innocenter parce qu'ils auraient perdu
de la crédibilité
mais il ya un mot qu'on n'a pas utilisée
aussi c'est la mentalité c'est ça c'est
que en france une drôle de mentalité et
quand je parle de la france il faut pas
dire oui tu es français ah oui je suis
fier d'être français je suis français
mais on est on est de mauvaise mentalité
là ya des ministres qui est arrivé et
qui veut faire parler d'elle trouve
attendez moi laissez moi finir parce que
je laissais dans les bocaux suite à la
non cet avis de faire parce que c'est si
je dis ça c'est que c'est bien vu c'est
notre leader
bien sûr je suis un des premiers à
lutter contre le dopage contre le sport
mais il ya une façon de le faire c'est à
dire arriver en france
essayer de casser les cyclistes chaque
sens que là je vous expliquer par
rapport la mentalité c'est que dans le
cyclisme
tous les français le savent que ça se
passe comme ça
les partenaires le savent le monde
entier et tout d'un coup soit disant on
sort un gros c'est comme ça en voulant
casser tout le monde pourquoi en ce
moment je veux dire que son dopage en
prépa le tour de france en vingt jours
je sais pas comment on est chez nous
bien sûr des juges mais c'est en ces
mots tu deviens il faut pas être faux
cul parce que c'est tout se moque et de
virac le chien foire était aussi pop moi
nous irons sont évoqués c'est aussi
parce que tu sois vous dites vous même
où tout le monde sait que tous les
coureurs sont dopés lors pourquoi lui
ben moquez-vous de te kiffe ou ou des
points contrairement à tous les autres
dit moi moi j'ai rien compris j'ai rien
à dire non c'est là c'est là où il
affirmé mais non mais quand il a fait sa
connerie lui la saq du tombe sur la tête
donc c'est difficile de quoi moi si
j'avais été à sa place je pense j'en
sais rien moi j'aurai tout dénoncer je
m'en fous moi je dénonce pour certains
mais que lui alors l'emploi us
il accueille ce projet n'a pas eu cette
force ou touchez pas il a été mal
conseillé
si on apporte vraiment dupe et aux
scolaires que vous avez m c'est vraiment
ça on avait l'impression il a raison de
mettre balle à jour du jeu on avait
l'impression d'un garçon qui était une
marionnette avec un avocat qu'utilisait
faut dire ça ça passe avec il a mis sur
la mauvaise maison vachement a besoin de
trop trop c'est trop il faut savoir
s'excuser je pense qu'ils ont été trop
loin très bien christine vous allez
conclure oui
ah non ah non pourquoi je vous signale
mais je vous signale quand même vous
êtes tous témoins qu'il a quand même dit
que il m'a tout à l'heure il m'a dit
quand même que j'allais lire 1 ben mes
poèmes d'accord la laddh va vous
présenter le journal de midi
vous voulez dire mais oui francis avait
bien adam et moi m'avait fait une
promesse de vente et moi donc je le
disais il attend la fin de l'émission
autre chose comme ça mais volontiers
alors ensuite érigé lire un poème alors
à christine alors voilà une des 100
épigrammes de de mon livre alors sur
deux maurincomme affectionner du bellay
sectionné de le faire du préfère l'amour
après je me signale à venir jusqu alors
attendez vous avez dit vous avez dit on
le lira juste avant de faire l'amour
donc je dis à quel style c'est ou non
mais ces jeux laverty l'international
élevé
tic dans le coin mais c'est pas grave
les délais les méchants dire j'en croise
un jeu changent de trottoir
voilà oui à la mairie pour une en effet
il a les cheveux me priver francis
lalanne juge alors non on ne peut dire
ça qu'à une femme alors je vais
commencer pas fait steen peut-être
épiler finir par vous ça va je ferai don
juan entre charlotte et et mathurine
quand je te vois je crois que c'est un
rêve mais dans le rêve était ce vraiment
toi car je ne sais trop vraiment si je
rêve puisque mon rêve n'est fait que de
toi quand je te vois je crois que c'est
en rêve et dans serais vous je ne vois
que toi je ne sais plus lorsque je viens
à toi si tu es vrai ou si tu es un rêve
ainsi soit-il de ce rêve de toi car
c'est par lui que ma vie est un rêve
quand je te vois
[Applaudissements]
le formateur vous avez du golfe
1 c'est plutôt bon il a ses coûts j'ai
connu la langue sous chapiteau six
heures de concert je suis passé leur
enfant caché que guy béart et avec des
piles et 3 patricia gagnon n'a plus qu'à
disparaître pendant l'amour oui
djamel bouras adresse lanta qui vous
reste un tatami quand j'ai un poème au
ses souvenirs pour la prochaine fois
piscine non mais bon qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire que les médias finalement ça
peut être la pire des choses et puis ce
qui vous arrive en ce moment c'est aussi
que les médias vous vous êtes je dirais
à vous protéger d'une certaine façon
c'est peut-être aussi par là où on a tué
ouais que peut-être le tendre la main
gérard ça vous fait quoi de voir
tirèrent dix ans de près ça me fait j'ai
l'impression d'être une victime des
médias comme je me gardais pour la
famille
on a très bien donc
piscine de villejean cours bonsoir merci
d'être vu merci pour votre courage en
tout les gars merci francis encore nous
voici au bataclan megalopolis et à
partir du 10 février au bataclan à
partir du 12 février chevrier et ça
s'appelle megalopolis d'accord et jamel
ils sont au zénith et amis ils à mettre
ces maisons pologne c'est sur vous que
ce tombeau il avait dit qu'on fait un
bon appel clair
voilà donc maintenant on passe au box
office a tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on prend des sondages qu'on a trouvé
dans les journaux le premier c'est dans
l'écho des savanes c'est un sondage ifop
et c'est un sondage sur ce que vous ne
souhaitez plus voir à la télévision
voilà alors il ya trois catégories il ya
les jt l'info les jeux et
divertissements les magazines et les
talk shows alors commencé avec jt info
alors vous me dîtes si ça vous semble
justifiée si vous êtes de la vie des
français
c'est un peu comme une famille en or
quoi c'est le même principe
alors chaque manche avec ppda ppda il ya
25% des français qui veulent plus le
voir aux jeunes c'est complètement
grotesque parce que c'est celui qu'on
regarde tous alors c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'on a pu le voir maintenant la
preuve on continue à leur gardien ait pu
voir on passerait sur la tuerie au
contraire on regarde ppda c'est qu'on
les aime bien parce que on a confiance
en lui quand ils vous envoient sur une
autre chaîne tf1 ils n'ont pas de souci
à se faire à vous je fais la promo anne
hommel celle là pour moi même j'aurais
dû me norange berne langnau ranger le
gland d'or c'est à des broussailles
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut regarder tv mais des
mavericks blandin pour le le prix de
l'animateur le plus flatteur du paf
voilà françois rollin ça vous étonne
bonne raison il ya vraiment un gars que
je veux plus voir la télé et vous avez
tous les mardis matin vous avez géant
miller je suis absolument pas d'accord
moi je suis pour qu'on avoir ppda
oui c'est le présentateur il a réussi
quand même à être un personnage de roman
c'est le présentateur de jt dont la vie
nous intrigue à monsieur re se trouve
qu'ils devraient continuer je vois pas
pourquoi ils s'arrêteraient et puis moi
j'aime bien sérillon mais quand même
comme il a présenté le téléthon pendant
dix ans à chaque fois qu'il annonce une
mauvaise nouvelle j'ai l'impression
qu'il va me réclamer du pognon
bon alors messieurs on est on est tous
deux dans la bas vous n'êtes pas dans le
jt l'info en or c'est pour dire le fait
que ses cheveux repoussent oui oui ça
c'est peut-être un peu le truc un peu
gênant pour lui c'est bien c'est un
petit postiches déposées avant la vente
continue michel field 11 % des mises en
fonction des français ne veulent plus
voir michel field
il le regarde pas d'accord sur y aussi
un sondage à la noue avec ses palaces et
l'ifop christine ockrent 10% vous payez
pas bon laissons à cette façon vous les
reprenez gratuitement pas beaucoup déjà
donc ont vécu cela plus avoir ça me
semble un peu débiles aussi cette
kouchner qui a répondu hier chazal 7% 7
% des gens seulement ne veut plus le
voir c'est pas beaucoup ça veut dire
qu'elle à 40 93 qui veulent l'horaire
plus les jaunes
vous voyez les gens si vous voulez
regarder et plus vous prétendez quand
vous dont on vous pose la question vous
n'avez plus envie de les voir vous êtes
sociaux la base mais déjà si si si oui
c'est vrai que ce sont ceux qui ont
l'âge de glace
alors je continue gildas 6% jean pierre
pernaut 5% à 6 5% sérillon la 4 % des
gens qui veulent plus le voir
béatrice schönberg 4% élise lucet qui
parle vous avez une drôle de façon de
commenter les sondages je ne pense pas
du tout que 96% des gens qui souhaitent
pour autant voir la personne en question
il y en a que deux captures non mais
c'est vrai mais la galette là parce que
vous avez répondu - m'aurait posé la
question d'abord je les connais pas tous
ont reposé la question j'aurais donc pas
répondu je ne voulais plus voir tel ou
tel personne sans pour autant souhaiter
autant la cour royale et drôle ça vous
pensez qu automatiquement lorsque vous
laissez là c'est pour ça vous êtes
l'agent miller
panda c'est débile et lorient il ya
20h09 aprilia 21 % des gens qui veulent
plus on voire aucun alors maintenant on
arrive à des choses beaucoup plus
sérieuses on arrive au magazine et tokyo
alors christine bravo 18 % des gens
veulent pu l'avoir aimé la regarde
il la regarde beaucoup sont 34 à la
regarder pour cent moi je regarde nous
connaissez nous mais on sait qu'il a des
mois là je prends ensuite à me regarder
géant m'a jamais demandé ça ne donnait
pas d'accord vous savez qu on accuse le
thermomètre danger mais moi je me dis
que c'est votre iphone oui voilà 18 %
des gens ont pu voir facilement l'avoir
moi ne me dérange pas tellement celle là
attention parce que là ardisson arrive à
harry sauvaitre troisième juste derrière
christine laure derrière drucker et est
vraiment c'était fin mai devant ce n'est
pas tant qu'ils bravo 18% drucker 13%
ardisson du personnage trop bas c'est un
truc qui me sens à ses adhérents de la
rue 8% dumas 7% mais dumas caen jeudi du
mat s'est pas relancé mireille durant 6
% courbessac vous connaissez courbet 5 %
des gens veulent plus le voir pivot 5%
courbes et son rayonnement condamne à
berne du bruit ce qui correspond
d'ailleurs en ce qui concerne l'arrivée
au nombre de gens qui le regardent
chaque appareil il ya le même nombre de
gens qui le regardent qui veulent plus
le voir bernard pivot de vecchi de voize
2% et aucun ne pas salir aucun 17%
c'est elle qui veut ceux qui veulent
garder tout le monde ils sont sympa
merci aucun voilà alors maintenant on va
passer aux gens qui vous en plus énervé
depuis qu'on s'est pas vu alors je vais
vous appelez roland lavoie
laurent laurent qui m'est le plus
énergique vous énerve en ce moment
écoutez il ya par exemple depardieu borg
j'aimerais j'aime beaucoup son talent il
est formidable et tout ça c'est sûr mais
dans la moi je suis allé voir la pièce
ah oui à moi je suis pas allée bien
dormi il y avait tous les politiques qui
étaient là charles quint signé jacques
attali c'était formidable
à part chevènement parce que mon avis
ils avaient peur de pas se réveiller
après la pièce
autrement je dois dire c'est quand même
c'est terrible attali d'arrivée lourd
venait voir ces semaines bon nom mais
pas les réveiller
mais c'est assez dingue way to politique
et elle a cédé paraît que ce n'est pas
son texte par deux au suspens très bien
son texte il disait paris à bar
garrigole paraît que jacques attali n'a
pas copié pour l asthme je trouve qu'il
aurait dû alors on peut rajouter on peut
rajouter quand même dans la catégorie
des gens qui énerve les chasseurs
on pèche c'est là d'un nombre de gens de
parler oui il faudrait peut-être dire à
ces chasseurs qui empêche par exemple
cohn bendit de parler que lorsqu'ils ont
des fusils et qui nous expliquent à
longueur d'année que ce sont des gens
pacifiques qu'on peut pas spécialement
dire lorsqu'ils arrivent cagoulés avec
des barres de fer peut il nous
convainquent exactement c'est vrai qu'à
une époque où il faisait peur aux crs
maintenant si heureusement entre les crs
sont là pour le protéger dans la main
oui mon passé non il paie
il ya quelque chose qui m'énerve mais
j'arrive pas à me mettre dans un camp ou
dans un autre c'est d'affaires miss
france
on a su il ya pas longtemps d'ailleurs
gérard était présent à france inter mais
le fontenay est la nouvelle miss qui
vient donc de tahiti puisque c'est miss
berry qui n'a pas été élu
contrairement au choix des
téléspectateurs de tf1 stéphane bern
faisait partie du jury et j'apprends
dans entrevue hier et ça je ne le savais
pas quand on a reçu madame de fontenay à
la radio il ya quelques jours j'apprends
dans entrevue est ce vrai que miss
tahiti serait la nièce de sacha distel
qui était parrain du jus répondait
stéphane l'her on nous avait pas
communiqué d'objectif a pas celui-là
voilà moi je vais j'ai été benoîtement
avait été abusé non non pas du tout et
je rebondis que mon stack
moi j'ai voté oui j'ai voté pour mais ça
y est restée la plus jolie et c'est la
seule quelque chose à dire parce que je
veux bien qu'ils aient une miss france
sur sa très marrant puis dire une reine
après tout ça n'arrive pas tous les
jours
alors pour une fois qu'on a une fille
qui est intelligente qui rase et qui est
belle quelque chose à dire m'attendais
elle a quelque chose à dire
j'ai pas envie qu'il y ait une godiche
une gourde à ce qu'ils aillent au bout
du monde on dire n'importe quoi pour
java courses amateurs de glisse qui vous
de moi je suis désolé mais elle tenait
pas la route
voilà à quoi l'a été avec sacha distel
c'est pas gagné non comme tout bon geek
et chantal comme dit patrick mahé très
justement elle a été recalé à l'oral
si vous citer patrick mallet on arrête
moi monsieur je trouve quand même si on
peut dire oui
une dernière chose à propos de ce
concours miss france je trouve
finalement très bien que tf1 ait choisi
plutôt le vote de son jury que le vote
de ses téléspectateurs c'est une belle
preuve de lucidité de la part de cette
chaîne que ne pas avoir confiance en la
matière les spectateurs mais aussi fait
20 morts avérés mais c'est comme tous
les deux ans
c'est comme toujours c'est comme tout
jugement alors un jury populaire dans ce
cas-là remettait en question le jury
populaire où elle les décisions des
magistrats
remettez en clonant on remet en question
mesdames messieurs c'était tout le riz
en mission ils assimilent bois sfl et
les berrichons qui étaient là en haut
sur minitel en train de pata bien
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir merci
géant miller merci françois rollin merci
cependant les faits tout le monde en
parle
rendez vous rendez vous dans quelques
semaines parce que les programmes soient
un peu chamboulé merci ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]